Caption: the AV and the live stream I believe so
Caption: please just hold tight we'll get started
Caption: perfect
Caption: all right
Caption: damn we did well all right right on time
Caption: guys so today uh we have Brandon Lewis
Caption: Here Brandon is going to talk to us
Caption: about the art of creative coding Brandon
Caption: has been developing software for about
Caption: 20 years and is currently a senior
Caption: manager of software engineering at one
Caption: of perth's largest mutuals he's
Caption: presented previously at DDD
Caption: and his previous chat was around uses of
Caption: blockchain outside of cryptocurrency
Caption: today he'll be exploring the question
Caption: can code create up over to you
Caption: oh
Caption: thanks thanks very much
Caption: um wow it's a good turnout thank you
Caption: very much for for coming
Caption: um really appreciate you taking the time
Caption: before we start I just want to thank the
Caption: sponsors for ddb Perth without their
Caption: generous support this event wouldn't be
Caption: possible so thank you very much for that
Caption: today what I really want to do is I I
Caption: have three objectives I'm hoping to sort
Caption: of inspire all of you to to try your
Caption: hand at creative art or creative or
Caption: generative art
Caption: um and create code or create art with
Caption: code
Caption: I'm going to show you some of the tools
Caption: that you might be able to use to do this
Caption: and some techniques some basic
Caption: techniques to sort of get you started
Caption: what you shouldn't expect is a math
Caption: master class so while there are there
Caption: are some relationships between
Caption: mathematics and creative coding I'm
Caption: still very much a student of maths more
Caption: so than a teacher so so don't expect any
Caption: any any math secrets to be honest
Caption: um
Caption: and web 3 and nfts big topics of course
Caption: uh don't expect to learn how to get rich
Caption: or Dogecoin or with Dogecoin selling
Caption: Profile Pics that's that's not what
Caption: we're here for
Caption: a bit about me
Caption: uh I've been developing commercial
Caption: software for about 20 years I've been
Caption: coding for closer to 30 at this point
Caption: I've worked across the entire software
Caption: stack from front end to back end and
Caption: everything in between I specialized in
Caption: integration for many many years before
Caption: moving into leadership roles and
Caption: proceeding with that as my my career
Caption: currently I'm a software engineering
Caption: manager at a large wa based Mutual where
Caption: I lead a bunch of awesome people to do
Caption: cool stuff and I support them in being
Caption: awesome
Caption: you can find me on all of the various
Caption: twitters and linkedins and and whatnot
Caption: and I blog about leadership in my my
Caption: blog at leader kaizen.com
Caption: of course I being a leader I don't
Caption: really code all this all that much
Caption: anymore in my work day to day so I have
Caption: to get my coding kicked elsewhere and to
Caption: do that I usually create my own projects
Caption: and work on things on the side in my
Caption: spare time
Caption: uh that's sort of how I came to to get
Caption: involved with unity and and learn unity
Caption: and develop game prototypes with it I
Caption: really enjoy understanding how those
Caption: processes and Mechanics Work and seeing
Caption: if I can create them myself it's a good
Caption: learning experience and and keeps my
Caption: skills
Caption: um current I suppose
Caption: it's also how I got into to shaders so
Caption: from from unity and learning mechanics
Caption: and and developing those things I got
Caption: into Shader development which is really
Caption: another gateway to to creative coding
Caption: and how I got into that
Caption: some of the examples of shaders I've
Caption: created are things like
Caption: Mr shaders for lava obscuring or objects
Caption: that are obscured and doing outlines and
Caption: and mixing uh messing with things like Z
Caption: buffer and whatnot to fake uh fake um
Caption: transparency and the light and some
Caption: Ripples and whatnot
Caption: um
Caption: but of course I haven't actually
Caption: finished a game and this tweet kind of
Caption: explains why uh that's that's kind of
Caption: that explains me really
Caption: but it turns out that my first
Caption: experience with creative coding was
Caption: actually many many years ago when I was
Caption: about nine years old
Caption: I joined a computer Club you know with
Caption: all the cool kids did right and got
Caption: introduced to logo uh in log with logo
Caption: you create you move a turtle around and
Caption: draw images on the screen and it's
Caption: actually used to to promote software
Caption: literacy and develop skills at a low
Caption: level
Caption: I didn't realize at the time of course
Caption: but it was um it was fun I suppose and
Caption: what I'd like to actually do is maybe uh
Caption: maybe share
Caption: some of the things that you could do
Caption: with logo because uh
Caption: that's pretty cool
Caption: of course being
Caption: this is a logo interpreter developed in
Caption: in JS and JavaScript available freely
Caption: and online I'll have links and resources
Caption: at the end of the attender presentation
Caption: but of course being nine this is kind of
Caption: what I created right like
Caption: as you've drawn on a piece of paper and
Caption: of course when your skills are limited
Caption: and you don't really know what you're
Caption: doing you kind of just
Caption: chaos right just chaos and just create
Caption: all sorts of random stuff that you think
Caption: looks cool
Caption: but it wasn't it wasn't until recently
Caption: that I realized you could actually do
Caption: some pretty cool things like uh some
Caption: depictions of mathematical algorithms uh
Caption: in in logo itself and I I thought that
Caption: was pretty cool so this is a this is an
Caption: example of Philo taxes which is a
Caption: um
Caption: it is the the way that leaves grow on
Caption: stems and plants so it's a it's a
Caption: biology biology thing which is tied to a
Caption: mathematical can be represented
Caption: mathematically and thus depicted in in
Caption: code
Caption: and I thought that was pretty cool
Caption: sorry
Caption: technical issues
Caption: yeah
Caption: real technical issues
Caption: cool
Caption: uh sorry
Caption: technology has evolved obviously since
Caption: uh since logo and the ability to create
Caption: to create such stuff is is a lot more
Caption: accessible and a lot easier to do
Caption: particularly with things available on
Caption: the web like you just saw I could do
Caption: logo with um through through a browser
Caption: which is really cool
Caption: but today I'm going to be showing you uh
Caption: p5.js and Shader toy which are two tools
Caption: that create art in very different ways
Caption: and I'm going to sort of speak through
Caption: how those differ but both tools are
Caption: web-based both are freely available
Caption: don't require any subscriptions or any
Caption: payments and you don't even have to
Caption: create an account on any of the sites
Caption: you can just kind of use them
Caption: uh there are there are comparisons that
Caption: you can draw between creative code or
Caption: creative or art generator through code
Caption: and traditional art and I like to view
Caption: them as the programs that you use or the
Caption: apps that you use very much the mediums
Caption: much like canvases and stone and wood
Caption: where they determine largely the thing
Caption: you're going to create so you don't you
Caption: don't create a sculpture with a canvas
Caption: for example and you can sort of view
Caption: tools in the same sort of vein and then
Caption: the algorithms and the the methods that
Caption: you use to create these things the code
Caption: that you create that's your brushes and
Caption: your pens and your chisels
Caption: uh
Caption: and so I'm going to talk through some of
Caption: some of those today as we work through
Caption: some of the demos
Caption: um generative art is I think and I'll
Caption: sort of take a small tangent here and
Caption: speak of nfts like I wasn't going to do
Caption: but I generally think that uh gender of
Caption: art is a real genuine use case for nfts
Caption: packaging the code along with the
Caption: parameters to create the thing I think
Caption: is
Caption: is very valuable and I think is a real
Caption: um there's a real benefit
Caption: and a genuine use case for nfts
Caption: uh
Caption: processing with p5.js so p5.js is the
Caption: first of the tools I wanted to speak to
Caption: you about today and it's it's based on
Caption: processing it's a flavor of processing
Caption: and processing was developed in I think
Caption: 2001
Caption: as a
Caption: as a software literacy tool it's a it's
Caption: a Java based Graphics library and IDE
Caption: that that you can draw stuff with it's
Caption: it is highly powerful and it's used for
Caption: things like simulations as well so it's
Caption: got a breadth everywhere from sort of
Caption: beginner level access to to very very
Caption: high level
Caption: the p5.js is a web implementation of
Caption: that as the name suggests leveraging
Caption: JavaScript
Caption: it does have a web editor or you can
Caption: build your own which I think is pretty
Caption: is pretty nifty
Caption: um as I mentioned it's it's really easy
Caption: to use really easy to get into and it's
Caption: reasonably well documented uh you can
Caption: there are enough similarities while not
Caption: a direct one-to-one Port of processing
Caption: the the similarities are close enough
Caption: that you could actually leverage the
Caption: documentation in tandem
Caption: uh it is I consider sort of a high level
Caption: language it abstracts a lot of the
Caption: difficulty and complexity in creating
Caption: some of this stuff quite well so for
Caption: example you can draw a circle you can
Caption: draw a square or if you're in 3D a cube
Caption: or a sphere and you'd also use vectors
Caption: and vectors is kind of we'll touch on
Caption: some of those but in a bit
Caption: um but having that control really
Caption: expands the possibilities that you have
Caption: uh and it's a bit more like I say a bit
Caption: more high level than than shaders that
Caption: we'll touch on a bit later
Caption: you can like I say do 2D and 3D stuff uh
Caption: so
Caption: um we'll we'll speak through some of
Caption: those as well
Caption: to give you an example
Caption: uh these are all created with p5.js so
Caption: as you can see very different uh in
Caption: style very different in nature and
Caption: I could speak particularly for the for
Caption: the um the one on the right that took a
Caption: lot of time and a lot of effort it's
Caption: really interesting how that came about
Caption: and the author or the the artist
Caption: um posts a really good blog post on that
Caption: which which I'll share in the slide deck
Caption: as well
Caption: that they they talk about how they
Caption: actually created it and it's fascinating
Caption: to see that actually
Caption: um come to life and come to fruition
Caption: long processed many months
Caption: and of course you can create animations
Caption: and I think that's
Caption: um that's one of the the strongest draws
Caption: of this in terms of uh in terms of
Caption: comparisons with traditional art and
Caption: it's something I think we as as
Caption: developers as coders have have an
Caption: advantage and we can create some really
Caption: cool animations
Caption: um with with things like p5.js and
Caption: Shader toy
Caption: so let's get on to some some demos right
Caption: Sans the technical difficulties
Caption: can you close that one
Caption: so
Caption: p5.js
Caption: you can go to built-in editor
Caption: I guess a super super simple if you want
Caption: to create a circle create a circle and
Caption: then we'll do it in the middle of the
Caption: screen so what's divided by two height
Caption: divided by two if I could type that'd be
Caption: great
Caption: and 50. and it's a radius of 50 or
Caption: diameter 50.
Caption: any credit Circle super easy
Caption: you change the color of the circle so
Caption: change the fill to I don't know
Caption: red Maybe
Caption: because red
Caption: yeah
Caption: red so
Caption: super easy to use and I think that's one
Caption: of the biggest draws in terms of getting
Caption: into it and just getting into creative
Caption: art and trying to learn how to to think
Caption: creatively rather than problem solve
Caption: it's a really easy barrier really low
Caption: barrier to entry
Caption: um
Caption: but you can also create things like this
Caption: right and
Caption: this is an example of something I
Caption: created with in collaboration with the
Caption: guys at maker X when trying to I suppose
Caption: defect or visualize earthquakes in an
Caption: interesting fashion
Caption: and we use kind of the number of circles
Caption: that it would generate as as the the
Caption: magnitudes would reflect those and then
Caption: plot them randomly or in turn or perhaps
Caption: in a geographical location and a line
Caption: that like that
Caption: but what's really interesting is that
Caption: there aren't any circles here
Caption: these are actually created just by
Caption: creating tangents tangents at regular
Caption: intervals and drawing a line and this is
Caption: I think where the real power we start to
Caption: see the real power or something like
Caption: p5.js where you can use vectors to to
Caption: project these things which are much more
Caption: difficult to do if you have to roll it
Caption: yourself
Caption: so what I actually do here is I take a
Caption: point in a circle I project a vector on
Caption: One Direction added to the other side
Caption: and then draw a line between the two and
Caption: I just do that for everything for 360
Caption: times and it kind of draws a circle
Caption: uh and I looked through through one of
Caption: the circle so it's still relatively
Caption: simple to do I'm not using any advanced
Caption: mathematics it's basic high school maps
Caption: and it creates some really interesting
Caption: stuff
Caption: but of course you can just keep creating
Caption: new versions
Caption: over and over
Caption: um or you could perhaps not even make it
Caption: random and you could take the circle out
Caption: and have it depicted elsewhere
Caption: the creative pot and this is where it
Caption: gets super super interesting is uh you
Caption: start off with something like this with
Caption: a simple idea
Caption: and then you try to expand upon it and
Caption: you could perhaps create something a bit
Caption: more like this
Caption: and this is completely different in many
Caption: ways to to the other but the code is
Caption: almost identical so what I do here is
Caption: instead of creating uh like 360 lines to
Caption: create a circle make them random and I
Caption: give them all different colors at
Caption: different points and just draw them draw
Caption: a number of them and Vary the alpha
Caption: randomly as well so you get the sort of
Caption: stringy sort of look
Caption: and of course oh if I was to remove the
Caption: seed
Caption: you can create a and create and create
Caption: all sorts of
Caption: different images and of course you can
Caption: constrain them so there I'm not really
Caption: doing anything anything to limit where
Caption: those things appear but you can you can
Caption: sort of do that and we'll get to some
Caption: examples that do that in a tick
Caption: um
Caption: but you can do something that's more
Caption: structured perhaps and something that
Caption: perhaps even mimics real life art so
Caption: like you're painting or something like
Caption: that
Caption: and this is an example that I pulled
Caption: together where I took a cityscape a city
Caption: um City skyline as
Caption: uh as um
Caption: as inspiration and I wanted to I started
Caption: off quite simply where I just had uh
Caption: true false
Caption: I thought about like that
Caption: and one of the things I really wanted to
Caption: experiment with was layering layering on
Caption: top of it to create this perspective and
Caption: adjusting the alpha at various levels to
Caption: to give that sort of perspective but
Caption: then of course that Evolution comes into
Caption: play and you're like well I want to try
Caption: I want to try to play with bezier curves
Caption: or bezier Curves and so I added clouds
Caption: as bezier curves bezio curves again
Caption: another example of how p5gs makes
Caption: something that
Caption: could be quite mathematically
Caption: complex if you wanted it to be it
Caption: doesn't have to be mind you but it can
Caption: be and makes it really simple that's a
Caption: simple simple function to create it uh
Caption: busier
Caption: so I kind of create those but then I
Caption: thought well what if I want to make it
Caption: look like a paintbrush instead of
Caption: something that's solid like that I mean
Caption: that that'll look cool and stuff but I
Caption: mean why not
Caption: this takes a bit of a bit of time
Caption: why not create to create a paintbrush
Caption: and the way I did that was now there
Caption: isn't a paintbrush you can't say hey
Caption: p5.js draw me a paintbrush or Draw this
Caption: in a paintbrush stroke pattern
Caption: um you have to create this manually and
Caption: that's just that's easy you take the
Caption: square and you PL take the pixels and
Caption: you just do one pixel at a time and
Caption: that's sort of why it takes a bit a bit
Caption: longer to do and we'll get into to how
Caption: this this is where one of the key
Caption: differentiates between this and Shader
Caption: toy that we'll talk about later sort of
Caption: comes into play
Caption: and then I thought well that doesn't
Caption: really look brush-like right so you
Caption: don't get the brush stroke at the end
Caption: and I wanted to just get brush Strokes
Caption: so I added
Caption: I add a little Randomness to the length
Caption: of each stroke so each line is going up
Caption: in a single pattern
Caption: and I'm just just randomizing the height
Caption: of that line each time to create a sort
Caption: of brushstroke
Caption: and the pallets I mean you might have
Caption: noticed that have pallets for or
Caption: different palettes for everything and
Caption: that's just a list of of Json uh Json
Caption: hex values and I'll load them in
Caption: and then randomly pick one that's that's
Caption: as simple as it gets really
Caption: speaking of bezier Curves
Caption: I think bezier curves are are a
Caption: beautiful illustration of maths they
Caption: that they're really simple in in nature
Caption: but they can make some incredibly
Caption: interesting shapes and I sort of took
Caption: inspiration here from you know the world
Caption: windows screen savers and sort of kind
Caption: of bouncing around that was the
Caption: inspiration right and and it's
Caption: I haven't colored any of these and
Caption: that's that's I think the the next next
Caption: phase is sort of what do you do with
Caption: these do you want to extend them so you
Caption: take something that's really simple in
Caption: just 40 lines of code and you can create
Caption: all sorts of different shapes
Caption: and you start to want to create a bit
Caption: your creative part takes over and you're
Caption: like well what can we do with that for
Caption: this particular instance I sort of took
Caption: one bezier curve and then just linked it
Caption: to another one but what if you made that
Caption: random at some in some way or what if
Caption: you had that deterministic in some other
Caption: fashion what if you added color what if
Caption: you added different shading to the
Caption: different lines then you start to get
Caption: some art right
Caption: a noise so uh
Caption: speaking of Randomness there is there is
Caption: a lot of Randomness in Creative code and
Caption: there's sorts of there's a few different
Caption: ways you can approach that right and
Caption: there's you can have it as either
Caption: completely random between two values and
Caption: it'll pick something
Caption: but sometimes you need something a bit
Caption: more nuanced a bit a bit more subtle
Caption: right and noise is a great way to do
Caption: that something like purlin noise for
Caption: example where it's a gradient of of of
Caption: Randomness it's something you can use in
Caption: this in when you want something like
Caption: this where you're only incrementing a
Caption: value by a small amount from the last
Caption: value every time and you sort of iterate
Caption: over that map of that purlin noise and
Caption: adjust the value accordingly
Caption: very very powerful again something that
Caption: is natively built into p5.js
Caption: sorry speech speak rules I mentioned
Caption: rules earlier where you want to sort of
Caption: constrain stuff and I suppose this is
Caption: more sort of software engineering
Caption: developery type of stuff
Caption: but you could constrain stuff like
Caption: Circle packing and you could say well
Caption: don't have any circles over that don't
Caption: create circles another Circle and create
Caption: some interesting diminishing patterns
Caption: um
Caption: and you can then extend that again
Caption: evolutionary well what can you do with
Caption: that perhaps you have that in certain
Caption: shapes you could have that along a
Caption: bezier curve so you have a bezier curve
Caption: and have the the circles all pack along
Caption: that curve within a certain radius and
Caption: create lines like that
Caption: or maybe you just want to represent
Caption: represent Doge right
Caption: because because why not
Caption: and and this is this is a really cool
Caption: example of just taking an image sampling
Caption: the pixel of where your point is and
Caption: then making the color of that Circle
Caption: that that pixel color and you can create
Caption: something like this and of course you
Caption: can you can adjust all of all of the
Caption: values and you can have uh circles be
Caption: bigger or smaller and you can do have to
Caption: make some changes to this to make the
Caption: image a bit more legible because if you
Caption: have massive uh massive circles you then
Caption: start to have huge Circles of one color
Caption: and you can't really get that definition
Caption: you don't really tell you not retail
Caption: what it is so I had to implement
Caption: something which would
Caption: grow it and then slow it down as it got
Caption: bigger so as the circle got bigger I
Caption: would slow the the growth down so that
Caption: it wouldn't really go past much a
Caption: certain size and it would give time for
Caption: more circles to fill in and pack it
Caption: foreign
Caption: taxes again so much like the logo
Caption: example I shared earlier but this time
Caption: with nice pretty colors and
Caption: I want to show this purely because I
Caption: want to show that the maths around it is
Caption: super super simple
Caption: and I think this is something which
Caption: initially
Caption: uh I found daunting when looking at
Caption: creative code I would see all these
Caption: things on Twitter all these things on
Caption: LinkedIn be like that looks really cool
Caption: but I'm sure that's really difficult to
Caption: do
Caption: and it's when you start to really dig
Caption: into it and you you even just look up
Caption: some of them you go into Wikipedia and
Caption: you look up what some of these equations
Caption: look like and they're not difficult but
Caption: they can create some really really
Caption: interesting patterns
Caption: um taking that a step further
Caption: and you can create
Caption: images like that that is the same
Caption: pattern just I'm now adjusting the size
Caption: of each of the circles and I'm coloring
Caption: it a bit differently
Caption: that's really it's the same code just a
Caption: bit different same same bit different
Caption: thank you
Caption: but it doesn't have to be all geometric
Caption: you can make stuff that's really random
Caption: uh really interesting and almost paint
Caption: like and this I sort of I tried to to
Caption: replicate or reproduce a Jackson Pollock
Caption: painting So with lots of just sort of
Caption: paint everywhere in arbitrary ways
Caption: um
Caption: and
Caption: this is sort of what it comes up with
Caption: but of course the benefit being code is
Caption: you can create
Caption: as many as you want
Caption: and you can tell that they're all
Caption: slightly different in terms of brush
Caption: sizes and that's all determined by the
Caption: code so I could limit it to certain
Caption: brush sizes or brushes or I could make
Caption: it go wild
Caption: patterns and and you can introduce
Caption: patterns to it and there's a really
Caption: interesting article I read about taking
Caption: an image and using the values of those
Caption: images or the color values of those
Caption: images to manipulate how the lines are
Caption: drawn so you end up having something
Caption: that looks like this but it has
Caption: structure within it I thought that was
Caption: really really interesting
Caption: um
Caption: but this is the re this is really the uh
Caption: this particular example is the the
Caption: technique I really wanted to go in depth
Caption: with a bit more because you sort of you
Caption: look at it and you can't it might be
Caption: difficult to see what's going on how you
Caption: create that
Caption: but when I found out how to create this
Caption: I was amazed how easy it actually was uh
Caption: uh and it's all very very logical and
Caption: it's easy to demonstrate as well
Caption: so you take a look at something like
Caption: this and
Caption: all it is is it's a it's a flow field
Caption: but it's created with vectors which I
Caption: mentioned earlier which again benefit of
Caption: p5.js
Caption: but that's what it looks like
Caption: so you take you take a grid you take a a
Caption: canvas you plot it into grids and you
Caption: can adjust the size of the grid as much
Caption: as you want
Caption: you then plot some purlin noise over
Caption: that
Caption: and then take vectors based on that
Caption: perlan noise so if your noise is zero to
Caption: one and you relate that to a radius or a
Caption: um to a Direction
Caption: you then direct the vector in that way
Caption: and because Pearl and noise is
Caption: Progressive it's it's you start to get
Caption: the sort of
Caption: feel this this motion as you will so
Caption: it's all like forces being applied and
Caption: all of the all of the directions that
Caption: you see here are just are the directions
Caption: of the flow field influenced by purlin
Caption: noise
Caption: and you can create of course I think
Caption: I've got this randomized I think maybe
Caption: possibly
Caption: I do like that seed
Caption: foreign
Caption: yeah but I can take a better seat how's
Caption: that
Caption: perhaps
Caption: I mean you could put an any seed rally
Caption: now I will I will confess there is a bit
Caption: of a bug in it and you'll see
Caption: occasionally you can see it here where
Caption: on the edges it sort of gets trapped
Caption: between two so again you get to you have
Caption: to do some problem solving as an
Caption: engineer and figure out well how do you
Caption: make
Caption: how do you adjust the the force or the
Caption: direction of those so that you don't end
Caption: up having these infinite loops on either
Caption: side
Caption: of course it can be adjusted even
Caption: further so if you wanted to for example
Caption: uh have it go longer so right now I'm
Caption: constraining the time so it only has a
Caption: certain amount of time to create
Caption: and it's it's that's probably something
Caption: I should have called out it's the alpha
Caption: that makes it do that so it's like
Caption: putting a whole bunch of pixels on the
Caption: onto the screen and then adjusting the
Caption: alpha gradually over time as you're as
Caption: you throw in all pixels and those pixels
Caption: kind of travel around and as they leave
Caption: more Trails you start to get thicker
Caption: thicker lines in the areas that they
Caption: travel
Caption: um
Caption: but it's the vector at the heart of it
Caption: it's the vectors that really that really
Caption: help to make this possible
Caption: but again super super easy right there
Caption: is nothing that should stop anyone uh
Caption: even someone with very limited
Caption: development experience or programming
Caption: experience to do this sort of stuff
Caption: so it highly highly recommend people try
Caption: it out
Caption: cool
Caption: and then
Caption: no
Caption: yes
Caption: cool so uh
Caption: p5.js in summary is a is a is a
Caption: fantastic tool for pretty much anyone to
Caption: get into creative code
Caption: it's easy to uh it's easy to get into
Caption: it's well well documented
Caption: but it's also a really good tool for
Caption: anyone with um with develop with
Caption: Advanced programming experience and the
Caption: reason I say that
Caption: is because I've only just scratched the
Caption: surface there is a breadth of of
Caption: capability there which you can leverage
Caption: I didn't even touch on the 3D stuff that
Caption: you can do but you can do 3D and it does
Caption: support shaders for example and you can
Caption: hook it up to all sorts of other sources
Caption: and it's fantastic for kids
Caption: um it if logo was what we were taught
Caption: sort of 30 years ago
Caption: um this is is what kids should be taught
Caption: now in my view
Caption: uh
Caption: extra benefit the skills are
Caption: transferable so JS you can transfer that
Caption: shaders uh
Caption: shaders with Shader toy
Caption: so as I mentioned earlier I got into
Caption: unli and that introduced me to shaders
Caption: and shaders are a c like
Caption: see likeish language
Caption: users see like see like language like
Caption: jlsl and hlsl
Caption: they are they are high level languages
Caption: but I would liken them to lower level
Caption: languages than say um p5js in that they
Caption: are assembly like it's not assembly by
Caption: any means but you you the way you have
Caption: to think about working with them is very
Caption: much assembly like they're used in the
Caption: graphics render pipeline for 3D stuff
Caption: and useful things like lighting Shadows
Caption: Reflections all that kind of thing
Caption: um
Caption: there are several different types of
Caption: shaders by the way so vertex shaders
Caption: geometry shaders and fragment shaders
Caption: they all do different things we're going
Caption: to focus primarily on fragment shaders
Caption: today
Caption: and what's really interesting is these
Caption: are some examples that were created
Caption: there isn't any 3D geometry in there
Caption: there are no triangles there are no
Caption: meshes there are no no quads no vertices
Caption: whatsoever that's all drawn effectively
Caption: drawn to the screen and a call out to
Caption: inio kiles who did the rainforest he's
Caption: got a fantastic YouTube video on how we
Caption: made that
Caption: absolutely worth a watch
Caption: and we'll get on to some more demos
Caption: before I get too far and I just want to
Caption: give a quick a quick sort of uh
Caption: Shakedown of what what shaders are in a
Caption: typical 3D environment you have a mesh
Caption: that's made up of vertices and some
Caption: lines between them creating triangles
Caption: then you can apply a material to it but
Caption: of course the material doesn't have any
Caption: value until you apply some light to it
Caption: so you get some light and you get a
Caption: material you can then also provide some
Caption: directional lighting and some shading on
Caption: the material
Caption: it's all of them all of the material
Caption: stuff is is the shadery bits is that
Caption: we're going to be talking about so we're
Caption: not going to worry about the vertices
Caption: today we're just going to be talking
Caption: about the shaders
Caption: sorry about the the fragment Shader
Caption: uh I'm going to skip these examples
Caption: because running low on time but head
Caption: over to Shader toy to check those out
Caption: because they're really really
Caption: interesting
Caption: um but the thing I really wanted to uh
Caption: the the method or or the technique I
Caption: wanted to share with you with regards to
Caption: shaders is Ray marching that is how
Caption: those images were done and it's a really
Caption: interesting technique to apply to um to
Caption: creative coding in general and it's you
Caption: can use that to create proper scenes or
Caption: you can create it create fractals and
Caption: all sorts of interesting stuff with them
Caption: and the whole notion of it is
Caption: um effectively looking at looking at a
Caption: scene and measuring the distance between
Caption: the camera and something in the scene
Caption: figuring out what's closer and rendering
Caption: that and you render it pixel by pixel
Caption: I think that's that's the key thing to
Caption: to bear in mind with shaders is you are
Caption: not actually saying hey draw me a circle
Caption: draw me a square draw me a cube you are
Caption: saying I want this color at this color
Caption: pixel at coordinate X Y to be this color
Caption: uh and that is all very mathematically
Caption: or can be very mathematically intensive
Caption: um so it's a bit more daunting to get
Caption: into and we'll get into that a little
Caption: bit
Caption: um but Ray marching is a process of
Caption: um determining the distance between
Caption: objects in the scene and your camera
Caption: so I created this little sort of demo
Caption: thing to sort of show how that might
Caption: work and I'm going to turn off all those
Caption: so say you started off with uh so you
Caption: started off with your camera in the
Caption: middle of the scene and we have array
Caption: that's going out from the scene
Caption: now so you add some objects into the
Caption: scene right
Caption: you want to you want to try and figure
Caption: out which so if I'm looking in this
Caption: direction what am I supposed to render
Caption: to the screen I'm supposed to render
Caption: number one at this particular pixel
Caption: so
Caption: how do we do that well we draw
Caption: lines we try to we go through we Loop
Caption: through the entire area the entire scene
Caption: and say well how far are you how far are
Caption: you how far are you and you try to draw
Caption: the closest but you don't want to draw
Caption: it to the to the origin of that you want
Caption: to draw it to the origin of the surface
Caption: of that and that's where stuff gets
Caption: interesting because that uses sine
Caption: distance fields to calculate where the
Caption: surface of it is based on what the
Caption: center or the origin is of that object
Caption: and you do that iteratively so you take
Caption: further and further steps as you get out
Caption: into the into the scene to figure out
Caption: when you've hit something so as you can
Caption: see here I haven't actually hit anything
Caption: because I haven't reached my minimum
Caption: distance
Caption: that I to get to the object haven't
Caption: realized that hey I'm actually at a
Caption: surface
Caption: but if you extend that further you start
Caption: to see it
Caption: expand
Caption: and you can see where you're starting to
Caption: actually hit things
Caption: and you return that back to your uh back
Caption: to your code and you say I'm going to
Caption: display pixel of this color at this
Caption: coordinate
Caption: so in a nutshell that is that is
Caption: remarking and that's used through
Caption: each of through the rest of these these
Caption: um these examples
Caption: I created a basic bootstrap Ray marching
Caption: Shader which will be in in in the
Caption: resources at the end of the slideshow
Caption: uh but essentially all it is is a basic
Caption: uh algorithm to to do ray marching and
Caption: the magic here all happens if they
Caption: forget the cult normal calculating
Caption: um happens sort of here
Caption: and for this example the
Caption: the distance for a sphere
Caption: if you want to calculate the science
Caption: distance field for the sphere is
Caption: calculated with this right now the
Caption: benefit is you don't have to worry about
Caption: having to work all this out some some
Caption: very smart people have already worked
Caption: out assigned distance fields for almost
Caption: every shape you can think of you then
Caption: take those and combine them and you
Caption: combine them using Boolean operators so
Caption: you can Union them you can subtract them
Caption: you can multiply them or add them
Caption: and that's that's effectively how you
Caption: would create a scene and for example
Caption: I created this for DDD Perth
Caption: where
Caption: it's just some lights going around but
Caption: there is no geometry in the scene right
Caption: this is all just I'm picking a pixel uh
Caption: in a screen based on this distance for
Caption: something and I can even show you what
Caption: that might look like if you take the the
Caption: O here for example
Caption: and this is when demo Gods strike me
Caption: down
Caption: uh so if I was to just return say
Caption: um the main o right so I'm returning the
Caption: distance to the main o
Caption: so yeah there we go and let's get a
Caption: sphere because that's all I started off
Caption: with but then what if I what if I
Caption: returned the minimum no actually I'm
Caption: going to do the maximum work
Caption: uh for the maximum value
Caption: of the main o and say the whole right
Caption: nope
Caption: Oh wrong one not bad
Caption: hold on let demigod strike me down
Caption: there we go
Caption: so what I've done here is I've
Caption: effectively negated uh the the main o so
Caption: the main o is no longer visible and only
Caption: the D's within it are right
Caption: but you can create a mask actually if I
Caption: do mask
Caption: that might you know oops
Caption: this is why you don't do live coding
Caption: people
Caption: um
Caption: so
Caption: by doing this what I've done is I've
Caption: I've created a an intersection between
Caption: the O and the mask that I've got for the
Caption: circle in the middle
Caption: and that's how you would you would
Caption: create a scene based out of
Caption: uh these Primitives that you would
Caption: create with sign distance fields
Caption: and it when you sort of when you start
Caption: to look at that you start to really
Caption: appreciate what some of these more
Caption: complex or complex images really take to
Caption: to create
Caption: it's a far more
Caption: I appreciate that experience a whole lot
Caption: more
Caption: of course the benefit is you can do
Caption: stuff like this as well
Caption: if you were to try and create this sort
Caption: of thing with a with traditional sort of
Caption: 3D geometry uh your machine would be on
Caption: fire
Caption: um and and so but you can you can do
Caption: this because you can do this in shaders
Caption: because you're not affecting you're not
Caption: affecting geometry you are effectively
Caption: changing the shape of the environment
Caption: you're affecting the environment not the
Caption: geometry itself so this is this this
Caption: whole
Caption: um field of spheres is created just by
Caption: by applying a modulo
Caption: to the sphere and it creates all of
Caption: these all these spheres
Caption: the the intersections or the uh The
Caption: Operators that I mentioned earlier and
Caption: because you're using sine distance
Caption: Fields allow you to do cool stuff like
Caption: if this this thing is close to this
Caption: thing take this point in this point and
Caption: if it's close enough together do
Caption: something with it and that's how you
Caption: sort of get this uh this glob effect
Caption: um I I'm really Keen to try and make
Caption: this into sort of metabols type of thing
Caption: or like a lava lamp I think that'd be
Caption: pretty cool
Caption: um
Caption: but you don't have to just do you don't
Caption: have to just do
Caption: sort of shapes and stuff again another
Caption: mathematical
Caption: Ingenuity or another mathematical
Caption: principle the mandelbrot set
Caption: and it's a depiction of it just zooming
Caption: in and it's
Caption: constantly evolving
Caption: and shaders are really good at doing
Caption: this because it you get to Leverage The
Caption: GPU to process and crunch some of these
Caption: things which is really effective and you
Caption: get to do some cool stuff with distances
Caption: from from various places
Caption: so all those are all those available on
Caption: Shader toy to take a look at
Caption: nope
Caption: so that did it work did it work no
Caption: it is changing here like it's changed
Caption: it's kind of semi-changing there but I
Caption: don't know I don't know man this is
Caption: so you just goes to show you no matter
Caption: how much you prepare tell you what
Caption: just
Caption: that uh
Caption: do that and go back
Caption: oh maybe I've just got to do that
Caption: no it's just not moving at all
Caption: like a moving slides here but it's not
Caption: moving
Caption: nope
Caption: oh there we go that'll do it
Caption: uh all that five uh F5 we'll go back
Caption: yay there you go so uh sorry about that
Caption: Shader toy requires a shift in mindset
Caption: and I think that's the key takeaway for
Caption: Shader toy in particular it's definitely
Caption: not as approachable as something like
Caption: p5.js it is mathematically intensive you
Caption: do have to think about how how you want
Caption: to solve problems and that can be a bit
Caption: daunting but it can also be very
Caption: rewarding as I personally prefer
Caption: creating stuff in in Shader toy and
Caption: creating shaders they they just sort of
Caption: Tickle My Fancy I suppose
Caption: um
Caption: but it also offers great opportunities
Caption: so things like fractals for example and
Caption: that's that's fair field you just can't
Caption: realistically do that in something like
Caption: ip5.js
Caption: um and I like the challenge right
Caption: but at the end of the day it's Different
Caption: Strokes of different folks there is no
Caption: best tool
Caption: so use whatever suits you so use
Caption: whichever is going to fulfill your needs
Caption: and think about what you want to create
Caption: what is the best tool going to be for
Caption: that
Caption: and more importantly I think try to
Caption: Master One I've tried to to sort of do
Caption: both and that's been that's been a
Caption: challenge I I don't think I've got very
Caption: good at either of them I'm still
Caption: learning
Caption: um so try to try to master one I've seen
Caption: I think some of that stuff that that
Caption: I've shown you today some of the other
Caption: examples
Caption: um those are from people who have
Caption: focused on on mastering one of them
Caption: so the key takeaways for today uh you
Caption: don't have to be an artist to create art
Caption: and I think it was Ralph Waldo Emerson
Caption: who said every artist was first in
Caption: amateur
Caption: so like try it don't be scared to uh
Caption: pick the tool that suits you
Caption: uh and experiment there is no right way
Caption: to do it and the creative part of this I
Caption: think is is the most important less so
Caption: than the coding it's being feeling free
Caption: to try and do new things
Caption: um I just want to call that that I've
Caption: all of this and everything I've learned
Caption: I've been standing on the shoulders of
Caption: giants and in particular these
Caption: individuals
Caption: and
Caption: especially the likes of Dan schiffman
Caption: who's got a who's authored a book called
Caption: nature of code which is absolutely worth
Caption: a read and in your keyless who is just a
Caption: master at Shader toy
Caption: thank you very much
Caption: alrighty guys thank you so much first of
Caption: all Brandon we've had a few technical
Caption: difficulties so we'll get that
Caption: off but thank you all for coming
Caption: um just a reminder we do have morning
Caption: tea in the foyer um so if everyone can
Caption: make a move there that would be
Caption: fantastic
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: uh okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends I'm Scott Hanselman and I
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck
Caption: this is like my dream come true I've
Caption: always wanted to join Scott henselman
Caption: too
Caption: foreign
Caption: what do you want
Caption: oh my chocolate
Caption: [Music]
Caption: questions
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three more days we need it ASAP okay
Caption: team what's the status on the app we're
Caption: good to go accept our login experience
Caption: is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the
Caption: keep that flawlessly because because I
Caption: don't want to lose one single customer I
Caption: hear you so let's use off zero off what
Caption: now off zero it's an identity platform
Caption: fast easy logins just what the boss
Caption: wants can we make our own authentication
Caption: Service come on the ultimate keymaster
Caption: you know we don't have that kind of time
Caption: we need to confirm identities with
Caption: passwords fingerprint scans whatever the
Caption: users like to use oh Siri can do that
Caption: yeah but it needs to be secure we can't
Caption: have our app compromised by breaches not
Caption: a problem and it needs to scale if we
Caption: get hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up I will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep I think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it I got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what I want a bodyguard hey we
Caption: got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's Stephen
Caption: what's up Stephen
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: thank you
Caption: all right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: uh okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: and I was told to give you a tour of my
Caption: office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: nerds nerding what we're doing is we're
Caption: talking to people all over the world
Caption: because we're stuck in our homes
Caption: what do you want
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a Fearless hunger for
Caption: Success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using AI to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a Children's
Caption: Hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at Insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young Brothers
Caption: to a Fortune 500 company offering I.T
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be now is
Caption: the time to do big things together now
Caption: is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: I'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case it might be
Caption: familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my color sign because I like
Caption: eating I eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me Carol why are you eating
Caption: and I think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: let's Carol
Caption: hi I'm Joe schneid I'm a test engineer
Caption: they call me gesture because I always
Caption: have a smile on my face whatever
Caption: situation I'm in
Caption: my name is Jayden I'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at Planet my core sign is
Caption: digit because I'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major
Caption: um but I often get called out
Caption: on how I never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths I just love maths
Caption: I am Cassandra I am a test at the
Caption: mission specialist being a beret as you
Caption: can tell by the Jackson I am French very
Caption: very premium accent so it's very
Caption: completely makes sense as for the pink
Caption: no matter the client no matter where I
Caption: was working it always was a pink
Caption: background with Hello Kitty riding a
Caption: unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who I am outside
Caption: clearly but I think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: um Sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: buried it is
Caption: my name is Kong I'm a consultant here at
Caption: planetmidt when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name I always say I'm not
Caption: the king but the Kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: I am the king and I'm the Kong work to
Caption: inspire is very something that we live
Caption: by I believe we definitely see how much
Caption: passion we have for quality and how much
Caption: we want to convey this as a client we
Caption: don't just go for Target we always try
Caption: to go a little bit further and we try to
Caption: inspire each other by learning new
Caption: skills having new challenges and taking
Caption: them and I think it's very inspiring we
Caption: better build better personally I always
Caption: try to be better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so I'm better than
Caption: yesterday and I'll be better tomorrow I
Caption: also got a lot of training opportunity
Caption: Planet because there's
Caption: a library of training courses available
Caption: that I can just access anytime before I
Caption: join Planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something Google first right and then
Caption: when you Google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what I want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and I
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so I can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work Planet
Caption: always encourages learning and learning
Caption: is a good way to just accelerate your
Caption: career growth Top Line of testing is um
Caption: it's awesome it's it's really cool to be
Caption: around people who are so passionate so
Caption: driven to do what they do and who always
Caption: want to want to learn and get better I
Caption: think that's really important and I
Caption: think it's going to be a driving Factor
Caption: going forward in in the IT industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top world is the best of the best and
Caption: for me it's uh if you want to grow up in
Caption: your career you are at the right place
Caption: because we have got all the training
Caption: materials right people and right
Caption: opportunities yeah what do you need to
Caption: progress in your career you have got
Caption: everything in here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: thank you
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: uh okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: with two of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: is nerds nerding what we're doing is
Caption: we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our homes
Caption: always wanted to join Scott have someone
Caption: what do you want
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while I was gone I made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then I helped him make his work much
Caption: better and we found the perfect outfit
Caption: to wear to my party
Caption: but I really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so I turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying Market leading Technology
Caption: Solutions through our life cycle
Caption: Services we help clients realize
Caption: business outcomes through our advice
Caption: integration and operational services
Caption: mlq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: all right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: all right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: alrighty guys thank you for coming to
Caption: our talk today so today we've actually
Caption: got a fellow Telstra purple senior
Caption: consultant with us Brenton 80. he will
Caption: be doing a talk on training a PowerPoint
Caption: AI to play Tic-Tac-Toe now he is
Caption: actually a tutor also for the University
Caption: of Western Australia data and analytics
Caption: boot camp he's got a pretty interesting
Caption: background with a Bachelor of Science
Caption: majoring in maths and psychological
Caption: science and a master of Applied
Caption: Artificial Intelligence on the way
Caption: daughter is a rapidly growing domain and
Caption: it is his vision to spread awareness of
Caption: the power that comes with taking control
Caption: of data over to you Brinton wonderful
Caption: cool
Caption: so uh pretty provocative title there uh
Caption: a little bit clickbaity uh surely this
Caption: is just a trick you might say just like
Caption: a play on words to get you through those
Caption: doors and don't worry we will get into
Caption: it we will get into this magical
Caption: PowerPoint AI
Caption: but before I talk about that we need to
Caption: understand what AI is what artificial
Caption: intelligence is
Caption: more specifically we're going to talk
Caption: about one Avenue that we get through to
Caption: get to AI which is machine learning
Caption: so
Caption: before we go any further
Caption: feel like I do have to warn you guys
Caption: this isn't actually a talk about
Caption: PowerPoint or tic-tac-toe
Caption: if you came in here hoping to get the
Caption: latest tips and tricks on creating
Caption: flashy slide decks and and mastering the
Caption: game of tic-tac-toe then well one I'm
Caption: profoundly sorry and two you maybe
Caption: should have read the talk description a
Caption: little bit more
Caption: there's time to leave if you want um
Caption: but AI then
Caption: AI is a term that floats around a lot
Caption: these days it's usually is some ex
Caption: machina style magic to solve all of the
Caption: world's problems which I mean it's great
Caption: for me because it means that I get to
Caption: wander around pretending like I'm some
Caption: Chris Angel in my day job analyzing data
Caption: but you see a magician never Reveals His
Caption: Secrets the difference here me a data
Caption: scientist I'm going to take you behind
Caption: the curtain and see how simple machine
Caption: learning and AI really are and how
Caption: applicable it is to so many different
Caption: scenarios more than you might expect
Caption: even say
Caption: PowerPoint
Caption: but if we're going to talk about machine
Caption: learning and some of you might be aware
Caption: of this then there's something we can't
Caption: avoid talking about
Caption: maths
Caption: that's right I tricked you all into a 45
Caption: minute lecture
Caption: grueling repetitive
Caption: complex maths
Caption: he's excited
Caption: except
Caption: we don't really need to talk about maths
Caption: to talk about machine learning as much
Caption: as I would love to get into intricacies
Caption: of stochastic gradient descent or
Caption: cross-entropy loss between distributions
Caption: those of you who just felt the blood
Caption: rush from your face as I mentioned the
Caption: word maths can relax just a little bit
Caption: but then that begs the question if we're
Caption: not going to talk about maths
Caption: what are we going to talk about
Caption: you see if you looked on the definition
Caption: of machine learning from our friendly
Caption: site Wikipedia you would get
Caption: machine learning algorithms build a
Caption: model based on Sample data known as
Caption: training data in order to make
Caption: predictions decisions without being
Caption: explicitly programmed to do so
Caption: that bit's important so keep it in the
Caption: back of your mind
Caption: but this is wild right this must be some
Caption: wild new innovation we've got sample
Caption: data we're making predictions and
Caption: decisions
Caption: except this quote is often attributed to
Caption: someone called Arthur Samuel
Caption: in 1952
Caption: Arthur Samuel was a pioneer of machine
Caption: learning in IBM and he was Building
Caption: Systems to play Checkers right back in
Caption: 1949.
Caption: but what about all this stuff I'm
Caption: hearing about neural networks computer
Caption: vision surely being able to get a
Caption: computer to see images that must be new
Caption: and wild right
Caption: this is a schematic for the Mark 1
Caption: perceptron this and is an initial
Caption: machine learning algorithm that was
Caption: trying to mimic the workings of the
Caption: human mind which sounds super fancy it
Caption: was used in early computer vision models
Caption: to for image recognition
Caption: in 1957
Caption: now although the technology has changed
Caption: a little bit the same fundamental
Caption: principles are still being used today
Caption: and are solely responsible for the
Caption: Resurgence we saw in neural networks in
Caption: 1990s
Caption: this might be a bit strange not what you
Caption: would expect
Caption: but you see despite what the buzzwords
Caption: might say machine learning is not just
Caption: for Big Data
Caption: machine learning is not just for
Caption: large-scale compute for people who have
Caption: all the money in the world to throw at
Caption: which maybe Microsoft will get mad at me
Caption: for saying um
Caption: machine learning is it's not Magic
Caption: if that's what machine learning is not
Caption: then what is machine learning
Caption: we're going to talk about what machine
Caption: learning is and hopefully by the end of
Caption: this you'll be able to come on me with
Caption: the come with me on the journey to how
Caption: we can create machine learning out of
Caption: something
Caption: stupid
Caption: machine learning is a way of
Caption: constructing a model that describes
Caption: things about the real world without
Caption: having to explicitly program it every
Caption: detail
Caption: in a way it's about transferring
Caption: Knowledge from the unknown from the
Caption: known to the unknown
Caption: and we do this sort of learning in real
Caption: day lives every day so much so that it's
Caption: pretty much second nature
Caption: when I was a kid I spent a lot of hours
Caption: playing the guitar
Caption: probably should have spent more hours
Caption: doing my hair
Caption: this is the sacrifices we make right
Caption: except for one time in high school where
Caption: we were auditioning for a musical which
Caption: the mic is important
Caption: um and maybe five six upwards of that
Caption: amount of people were trying to audition
Caption: for guitar but no one was auditioning
Caption: for Bass and I said
Caption: how hard can it be going from six
Caption: strings to four
Caption: easy
Caption: except any musician who is tried to
Caption: transfer from guitar to Bass will know
Caption: that there are transferable skills
Caption: there's a lot more knowledge that you
Caption: need to gain before you can successfully
Caption: play the bass my first few performances
Caption: I absolutely bombed
Caption: I thought I started out thinking that I
Caption: would have all my knowledge in guitar
Caption: that would easily transfer it into
Caption: um bass but this wasn't the case it was
Caption: only after successive practicing
Caption: learnings failings that I managed to get
Caption: to where I am today
Caption: put it another way let's assume we have
Caption: a group of people much like yourselves
Caption: tasked with predicting the result of a
Caption: coin flip
Caption: and for every correct guess you get a
Caption: cookie that's just so that we make sure
Caption: that people take this very serious
Caption: experiment seriously
Caption: without prior knowledge except for the
Caption: fact that maybe a coin has two sides I
Caption: think we can agree within a certain
Caption: margin of error that 50 of the group
Caption: will get a cookie
Caption: so we run this one flip turns up heads
Caption: two flips turns up heads
Caption: three flips heads and what a coincidence
Caption: some might say others might start to
Caption: catch on
Caption: four flips turns up heads
Caption: five flips turns up heads and a group
Caption: start might start getting suspicious
Caption: cookies are flying left and right
Caption: given enough time people will learn the
Caption: ploy of this con man
Caption: tis No Ordinary coin
Caption: the group starts around here 50 percent
Caption: but then with successive coin flips and
Caption: the promise of cookies getting ever more
Caption: enticing we start to learn with coin's
Caption: true nature nature
Caption: by guessing and getting it wrong or
Caption: guessing and getting it right and being
Caption: rewarded constantly over and over again
Caption: we can start to induce that the
Caption: information is not that the coin is a
Caption: regular coin but it is a double-sided
Caption: double-headed coin
Caption: so
Caption: what is that how can we abstract that
Caption: away from that experience of us learning
Caption: after successive coin flips and apply it
Caption: to Something in the maths world or the
Caption: computer world
Caption: there are many types of machine learning
Caption: that you might have heard of supervised
Caption: unsupervised reinforcement learning
Caption: semi-supervised
Caption: but fundamentally they all follow the
Caption: same three basic steps
Caption: we need to create a test
Caption: what is the model trying to do
Caption: we need to define a way to score the
Caption: test
Caption: how well do we how do we tell if a model
Caption: is good or bad or what it's trying to do
Caption: and lastly most importantly we need to
Caption: find a way to punish or reward the model
Caption: for the score it received
Caption: so again the idea here is that if we
Caption: take the fundamental components of what
Caption: a machine learning algorithm is
Caption: stripping away all the maths complexity
Caption: and high compute power we can find ways
Caption: to implement it in something simple and
Caption: we need to know these steps if we're
Caption: going to build an AI from the ground up
Caption: with machine learning in say
Caption: a PowerPoint maybe I don't know is that
Caption: why you're here
Caption: indulge me for a minute while we walk
Caption: down metaphor Lane
Caption: we're going to open up Brenton School of
Caption: machine learning studies
Caption: in this school we have students day in
Caption: day out trying to produce results
Caption: school is the model and our students are
Caption: just instances of training that model
Caption: get this school to learn and perform in
Caption: one of the top schools
Caption: we need to define a test
Caption: this test is how we're going to judge
Caption: how well the school performs when we
Caption: conduct tests each student will get a
Caption: score and our student score is and our
Caption: school score is some aggregation of the
Caption: student score
Caption: who doesn't love standardized tests
Caption: right
Caption: after the test we need to Define what it
Caption: means to pass or fail it
Caption: what does it mean for a student to do
Caption: well in the test what is a good score
Caption: what is a bad score for the school
Caption: what will end us end up in US losing
Caption: your funding and turning off the lights
Caption: forever
Caption: lastly we need to Define how we're going
Caption: to punish the students who have failed
Caption: and reward those who did well
Caption: this is a standardized test and again
Caption: our school will be based off the
Caption: aggregated score of all of our students
Caption: so we want to maximize the amount of
Caption: students passing
Caption: by whatever means necessary
Caption: and we do this many many times
Caption: each time a student is getting punished
Caption: if it gets the test wrong or it's
Caption: getting rewarded if it's doing it better
Caption: it's important to note here that the
Caption: students are the one learning after each
Caption: test they are what makes this machine
Caption: learning school a machine learning model
Caption: and you can't just go ahead and reward
Caption: or punish your school in as a whole
Caption: anyone who's tried to organize any group
Caption: of kids will know that that's just not
Caption: possible what you do have control over
Caption: is the individual students running their
Caption: tests and you have the ability to learn
Caption: to get them to learn or change their
Caption: scores
Caption: now you might say a different approach
Caption: to this is to try and get every student
Caption: to memorize the answer of every single
Caption: test question in the test which yes it's
Caption: an option it will get a pretty good
Caption: score but then say a new school board
Caption: runs around and says we don't like this
Caption: test we're going to define a new one all
Caption: of a sudden you have to do all of the
Caption: rework and getting all of these hundreds
Caption: thousands of students in the school to
Caption: relearn their answers it's not efficient
Caption: and I know that I can't memorize a
Caption: standardized test for the best of days
Caption: the key thing here is that you can run a
Caption: test on any model but if there exists no
Caption: process to punish or reward the model
Caption: based on the test score then it's simply
Caption: not a machine learning model
Caption: so that's a little bit of fun down
Caption: metaphor Lane but let's look at this in
Caption: the real world
Caption: what you're looking at here is an
Caption: example of the mnist data set it's sort
Caption: of said as the hello world of computer
Caption: vision whatever that's worth
Caption: data set containing 70 000 labeled
Caption: handwritten digits
Caption: uh 10 60 000 of those are training and
Caption: ten thousand of those are testing
Caption: the name of the game is to get a model
Caption: that classifies an unseen hand written
Caption: digit as zero through to nine
Caption: so in this case our test is pretty
Caption: simple is the predicted digit equal to
Caption: the actual labeled digit
Caption: so if we try and approach this in the
Caption: simplest way possible
Caption: our first model might be
Caption: random guess
Caption: this is about as simple as we can get we
Caption: just simply ran get randomly guess a
Caption: number between 0 and 9 and assign the
Caption: label to be that
Caption: this model is quite easy to test
Caption: actually in fact if we did it then we
Caption: would find that it's about 10 accurate
Caption: and that's much like guessing a random
Caption: coin is 50 right accurate
Caption: however
Caption: we have no way to change the model's
Caption: behavior when it gets things right or we
Caption: can't alter it when it gets things wrong
Caption: our model's accuracy will always be 10
Caption: percent
Caption: hence I'm a model is not a machine
Caption: learning model
Caption: so 10 percent not that great one in
Caption: every 10 digit gets it wrong
Caption: so let's try a better approach
Caption: this time we're going to relate a model
Caption: to the image's darkness which might seem
Caption: a bit strange but you might expect an
Caption: image of an 8 to be darker than an image
Caption: of a one and maybe a little bit darker
Caption: of an image of a three
Caption: it's more ink involved so there's more
Caption: Darkness
Caption: this model is a little bit better in
Caption: practice we see that the accuracy
Caption: averages to about 22 percent which is
Caption: twice as good as randomly guessing
Caption: but it's still only one in four one in
Caption: five getting it right
Caption: I think
Caption: we can do better than that
Caption: crucially again there was no way to
Caption: alter the model's Behavior
Caption: when it's dark and it predicts it to be
Caption: an eight it'll always do that regardless
Caption: if it was just a really heavily uh
Caption: highlighted five
Caption: so let's see if we can apply what we
Caption: just learned in the school metaphor for
Caption: for creating machine learning algorithms
Caption: don't worry about the code in two
Caption: details this is an extract taken from a
Caption: book that I dearly love called neural
Caption: networks in deep learning by Michael
Caption: Nielsen
Caption: for those interested this is uh what
Caption: this is again what we call a neural
Caption: network
Caption: but crucially what this has is what the
Caption: other two models didn't it has a way to
Caption: reward good test scores and punish bad
Caption: ones
Caption: every times it runs its own tests it'll
Caption: find a way to calculate how different
Caption: the predicted value was from the
Caption: expected value
Caption: and then alter the model in some way
Caption: that favors the way that it got it right
Caption: the key magic in here is uh we're feed
Caption: forward back propagation approach this
Caption: takes the output of a cost function
Caption: cross entropy in this case to test how
Caption: how different the prediction was from
Caption: the expected and it Alters the model uh
Caption: based on stochastic gradient descent
Caption: which honestly it's pretty simple it's
Caption: just based on the train rule of deriving
Caption: matrices
Caption: except I said no maths
Caption: I'll breathe
Caption: the model here is a machine learning
Caption: model
Caption: it had a test the is the predicted value
Caption: equal to the actual labeled digit
Caption: it has a way of determining a good or
Caption: bad score in this case I said it was the
Caption: cross entropy function
Caption: and it has a way of altering the model's
Caption: Behavior the stochastic gradient descent
Caption: you don't have to know how it works you
Caption: just have to know that it's there and
Caption: there's a method of applying this
Caption: punishment or reward
Caption: thank you
Caption: but
Caption: the mnist is a pretty typical example I
Caption: said it was like the hello world of
Caption: computer vision
Caption: in it we had a very clear labeled
Caption: objective
Caption: if our model
Caption: didn't predict the correct label for the
Caption: digit then it's not up to scratch
Caption: sometimes the test and the score aren't
Caption: so clear-cut
Caption: the interesting examples in the industry
Caption: around the test isn't so clear and a bad
Caption: score is equally just as vague
Caption: see labeling digits is easy
Caption: but what about if you're trying to just
Caption: transcribe somebody's piano playing and
Caption: as an audio file and transcribe that
Caption: into manuscript music that somebody
Caption: would read
Caption: this is a paper uh called onsets and
Caption: Frames dual objective piano
Caption: transcription and they try to do just
Caption: that
Caption: now the paper is full of fun maths and
Caption: data science jargon but the point of
Caption: Interest here is when the authors tried
Caption: to describe how they base the model
Caption: accuracy for velocity
Caption: as they say it's been a pretty hard nut
Caption: to crack I mean sure you can tell if a
Caption: note written on paper is the same as the
Caption: note what was played you can even test
Caption: whether the transcribe for note falls on
Caption: the same beat give or take
Caption: but how do you capture Dynamics volume
Caption: expression
Caption: a note pitch is a note pitch but what
Caption: reference does a note's loudness have
Caption: who's to say the recording just isn't
Caption: really loud or there's a lot of
Caption: background noise
Caption: additionally how do you correct a given
Caption: notes volume based on the content when
Caption: the context that it appears in is
Caption: arguably more important
Caption: a soft note compared to a really loud
Caption: note
Caption: has different uh meanings than if you
Caption: just have a sequence of soft notes
Caption: so I love academic papers the authors
Caption: are kind of hand wavy at this point
Caption: they're saying that they've discovered a
Caption: never-before-seen method to truly test
Caption: whether their model perfectly
Caption: transcribes the Dynamics of a player
Caption: Forte fortissimo piano
Caption: however it's important to note that all
Caption: that's been done is some math magic to
Caption: calculate a score based on the average
Caption: volume of the recording
Caption: they didn't discover any brand new
Caption: method they simply defined a test
Caption: the test could have easily been all
Caption: notes of the correct volume if they're
Caption: below negative five decibels
Caption: that's a test and the model would have
Caption: been really good at transcribing all
Caption: notes that are below negative five
Caption: decibels
Caption: so these are the three key things that
Caption: we've got to keep in our minds moving
Caption: forward
Caption: to have a machine learning model you
Caption: have to have a test
Caption: school and then a way to punish or
Caption: reward based on that score
Caption: sometimes these are pretty easy to
Caption: understand say for example if is your
Caption: digit equal to the labeled digit
Caption: sometimes it can be a bit more vague in
Caption: the case of when you're trying to
Caption: transcribe music notes or when you're
Caption: trying to
Caption: play Tic-Tac-Toe for example
Caption: so that was a lot
Caption: but this creates the fundamentals of
Caption: what we're going to use as we go through
Caption: the Journey on how you might do
Caption: something strange
Caption: see machine learning is more than just
Caption: classification and regression
Caption: learning can be used in any application
Caption: that uses the three key principles when
Caption: you define a test when you calculate a
Caption: score and then provide some sort of
Caption: punishment or reward
Caption: and if you don't believe me well
Caption: this is where the fun comes in
Caption: training and AI to play Tic-tac-toe
Caption: except
Caption: that might not really get you convinced
Caption: right maybe I'm just going to pull out
Caption: my Python and do some math magic and
Caption: then that doesn't convince you at all
Caption: what about if we tried to find a
Caption: scenario in which we didn't have any of
Caption: that available to us we don't have any
Caption: code we don't have any fancy compute
Caption: yeah I think this will do a better job
Caption: I mentioned before Arthur Samuel who
Caption: spent a large part of his career
Caption: utilizing the best IBM computers at the
Caption: time to create revolutionary new machine
Caption: learning programs
Caption: I wonder what he'd think if he saw his
Caption: whole what life's work reduced to a
Caption: slide deck
Caption: now in true typical consultant fashion I
Caption: will label some caveats here and really
Caption: Define the scope of what we're going to
Caption: be working with
Caption: the aim of the game is to demonstrate
Caption: that machine learning is no more
Caption: complicated than any other algorithm
Caption: once stripped down to its fundamentals
Caption: hence
Caption: no code is allowed
Caption: now full disclosure I did use some
Caption: macros as you will soon see to get this
Caption: working involved many slides and
Caption: many
Caption: many animations so
Caption: to save myself an eternity I hacked some
Caption: old VBA scripts to automate the
Caption: insertion of animations and slides we
Caption: will not be using these in the method
Caption: for training the PowerPoint I want to
Caption: make that very clear
Caption: secondly for the game theorists out
Caption: there there is about uh 255
Caption: 168 possible games of tic-tac-toe
Caption: this number varies slightly depending on
Caption: how you define what a game of
Caption: tic-tac-toe is but needless to say
Caption: that's a very big number
Caption: um so to narrow this down I've reduced
Caption: the problem to training a PowerPoint
Caption: tic-tac-toe to win in three moves or
Caption: more likely it's uh training a
Caption: tic-tac-toe to not lose in three moves
Caption: but you know that doesn't that's not as
Caption: catchy
Caption: in addition the AI will always make the
Caption: first move and always in a corner
Caption: see the game of tic-tac-toe actually
Caption: varies quite significantly depending on
Caption: which player goes first so we're going
Caption: to just highlight one example of this
Caption: game state
Caption: where possible we'll utilize Reflections
Caption: and rotations so that a computer will
Caption: never make a move that is a reflection
Caption: or rotation of another state that it can
Caption: move to
Caption: what does that mean in this example
Caption: there are only three places that an AI
Caption: will try to place
Caption: itself
Caption: the left the bottom left and then the
Caption: bottom this is because the other blank
Caption: spaces are just reflections of those
Caption: moves the right and bottom right are
Caption: just reflections of the left and bottom
Caption: left
Caption: us human players will have no such
Caption: restrictions
Caption: this leaves us with a still not tiny
Caption: number of
Caption: 1830 possible game states that you can
Caption: have for Tic-tac-toe
Caption: I'll take the time here to thank The
Caption: Inspirations uh that cursed me with this
Caption: project first was the work by
Caption: mathematician and comedian there are
Caption: some of us who are funny by the name of
Caption: Matt Parker who ran a project and
Caption: training a machine learning algorithm to
Caption: play Tic-Tac-Toe based on a set of
Caption: matchboxes and this was off the work of
Caption: Donald Mickey in 1961.
Caption: if you ask me they're kind of cheating a
Caption: little bit they only have to deal with
Caption: this approximately 700 possible states
Caption: that the tic-tac-toe board can be in and
Caption: there was a lot of human intervention so
Caption: you know like throwing any shade but
Caption: the second uh was a video by Tom
Caption: wilderheim who really opened my eyes to
Caption: the programming potential of PowerPoint
Caption: in his absurd ideas in computer science
Caption: PowerPoint programming it's a great
Caption: watch
Caption: so PowerPoint then
Caption: now I've heard from the streets that
Caption: some people are under the false
Caption: impression that PowerPoint is not the
Caption: greatest tool ever invented
Caption: laugh I'm shocked I mean PowerPoint has
Caption: literally everything you could want from
Caption: a programming language
Caption: it has text
Caption: it has
Caption: shapes
Caption: and most importantly
Caption: has animations
Caption: that's a totally random animation by the
Caption: way the first time I'm seeing it it's
Caption: always fun
Caption: you may laugh but the shapes and
Caption: animation is actually the key to what
Caption: allow us to form a real machine learning
Caption: model with PowerPoint
Caption: because they allow us to do something
Caption: that developers take for granted every
Caption: day
Caption: management
Caption: in our model each slide will represent a
Caption: particular move from either the player
Caption: or the AI
Caption: we will then use these shapes and
Caption: animations to manage that state to
Caption: remember what they learn
Caption: so our model will consist of
Caption: 1830 states which is one thousand eight
Caption: hundred and thirty slides
Caption: each slide State consists of the
Caption: following
Caption: simply the board which is the number of
Caption: naughts and crosses in their relative
Caption: positions to each other in this case AI
Caption: is cross and human player is not uh that
Caption: just felt right I don't know
Caption: and also we also contain all of the
Caption: previous steps that got us to that state
Caption: using one of my favorite PowerPoint
Caption: features Zoom transitions
Caption: so this encodes all of the information
Caption: that got us to the state that we were in
Caption: it allows us to pop back propagate
Caption: through each path and get to the slide
Caption: that led up to it
Caption: so that's the state that's that's what
Caption: we're trying to capture in a slide but
Caption: how do you transition from one state to
Caption: another
Caption: well there are two different types of
Caption: turns there's a player's turn and an
Caption: ai's turn
Caption: for the player a collection of shapes
Caption: that place a naught and navigate to the
Caption: relevant slide or on every single Blank
Caption: Space
Caption: they're invisible so they don't have any
Caption: fill color or outline color but they do
Caption: have a hyperlink to the slide that is
Caption: relevant
Caption: every click on an empty space navigates
Caption: the user to a new slide where that knot
Caption: is in the location that was clicked so
Caption: for this slide there are eight invisible
Caption: shapes but they are there and they
Caption: hyperlink to the relevant slide when a
Caption: user clicks one
Caption: we go to that slide and notice in the
Caption: top left hand corner we've saved the
Caption: state of what it was previously by using
Caption: the zoom transition
Caption: so that's the player but what about the
Caption: AI how do we get the AI to navigate
Caption: and this is where things get interesting
Caption: now to be sure a human player still
Caption: clicks the AI we're not building a
Caption: PowerPoint to control a mouse just yet
Caption: although don't give me any ideas
Caption: for the AI there is also a collection of
Caption: invisible shapes but these these ones
Caption: blink at semi-random intervals the
Caption: difference between this navigation and
Caption: the previous navigation is that all the
Caption: shapes are in the same place except only
Caption: one is visible at a given time
Caption: when a user clicks on the button labeled
Caption: click to make AI move I have no ux
Caption: designer but that's pretty
Caption: self-explanatory it instigates the
Caption: animations of each shape lawet clicking
Caption: so this is for demonstration in reality
Caption: those shapes are invisible and they're
Caption: clicking they're blinking a lot faster
Caption: and there's a lot more of them
Caption: so that's it
Caption: our model consists of
Caption: 1830 game stats 301 of those each have
Caption: an AI making a random choice to proceed
Caption: to the next move
Caption: now I say random choice
Caption: currently we're set at a ground state
Caption: for the model
Caption: and think of ground state as just
Caption: predicting 50 50 on a coin toss
Caption: what we want to do is to change from
Caption: that ground state into a state that is
Caption: optimized for playing Tic-Tac-Toe
Caption: how are we going to do that
Caption: let's call back to what we learned just
Caption: a few minutes ago
Caption: we're going to use machine learning so
Caption: we need to define a test
Caption: a score and a way to punish or award the
Caption: AI for making bad or good moves
Caption: so if we do this we can verify that what
Caption: we've indeed created is a machine
Caption: learning model an AI for in a PowerPoint
Caption: to play Tic-tac-toe
Caption: first our test
Caption: due to the limited time of a lone man's
Caption: calendar and the absurd amount of games
Caption: of tic-tac-toe I said that this test is
Caption: does the AI win in three moves the
Caption: converse is true does the AI lose in
Caption: three moves
Caption: next our score
Caption: now the number of winning games is not
Caption: evenly distributed among the total
Caption: number of games of tic-tac-toe what I
Caption: mean by that is there are far more games
Caption: where neither the player nor the AI win
Caption: so for this score we're going to
Caption: consider three results pass the AI wins
Caption: neutral neither the player nor the AI
Caption: wins and three the AI losers
Caption: passing represents the best possible
Caption: score that we could get I want to
Caption: encourage this as much as possible
Caption: because it happens so few times
Caption: um the failing is a bit more common but
Caption: we want to discourage this from
Caption: happening and neutral is pretty much the
Caption: most common
Caption: so
Caption: this translates to how we're going to
Caption: punish a reward
Caption: when an AI passes and it wins in the
Caption: first three moves we want to give it an
Caption: extra chance so that it will navigate to
Caption: each slide that leads to a winning move
Caption: that's signified by a plus three chance
Caption: neutral nothing happens we don't want
Caption: our AI to just lose all of its chances
Caption: to navigate
Caption: fail is we take away the chance to
Caption: navigate to the particular slide that
Caption: made it end up in a losing position
Caption: so
Caption: how are we actually going to do this
Caption: this is the fun bit this is the reason
Caption: why we had to have that absurd
Caption: arrangement of shapes blinking and all
Caption: of them on the slide
Caption: it's also why we have to stay save the
Caption: previous state that we were in
Caption: throughout the whole path of the game
Caption: foreign so I said that each move in the
Caption: AI state has a
Caption: absurd amount of blinking shapes now
Caption: these shapes represent the probability
Caption: of moving from one state to another
Caption: in the ground state I've initialized it
Caption: with 10 shapes each to move to each
Caption: available location than a I can move
Caption: into
Caption: in this slide there are 70 7 places that
Caption: the AI can move to they're the blank
Caption: spaces because there's no symmetry here
Caption: and because there's a initialized for
Caption: the 10 shapes each to navigate to those
Caption: slides there are 70 randomly blinking
Caption: shapes on this slide
Caption: each one representing a chance to
Caption: navigate to the state that we're going
Caption: to move to
Caption: so
Caption: when an AI runs a test if the results
Caption: were good that is the AI wins in the
Caption: first three moves then we will track the
Caption: moves it took to get to that state this
Caption: represents the best possible play that
Caption: an AI can make somewhere along the line
Caption: the player has made a mistake and the AI
Caption: has a chance to win and it does
Caption: we want to reward this as much as
Caption: possible
Caption: what I mean by that is we want to reward
Caption: every state that came before it to
Caption: appear again
Caption: so
Caption: we add more of those shapes that are
Caption: randomly blinking the hyperlink to those
Caption: slides
Caption: and we back propagate through every
Caption: state with that so it starts with no
Caption: things no pieces on the board
Caption: when we click the AR moves we want to
Caption: encourage it then to move to the next
Caption: state in which it will win
Caption: however
Caption: let's say the AI makes a bad play
Caption: somewhere along the line it might have
Caption: even had a chance to win
Caption: but then it doesn't it makes some sort
Caption: of fatal error and leaves it open for
Caption: the player to come in and attack
Caption: we want to discourage this from
Caption: happening if it's in a position where it
Caption: can either win or Draw we don't want it
Caption: then navigating to a slide which
Caption: represents a state that a player can
Caption: then win
Caption: so every time we run a test and it loses
Caption: we back propagate through every slide
Caption: that we have and take away one of those
Caption: shapes that navigates to the slide that
Caption: ends up losing
Caption: and that's for every single slide along
Caption: the path
Caption: this way when it's at a fork in the road
Caption: when it doesn't know where to put it
Caption: there is more chance that it will move
Caption: to a slide that wins or is neutral but
Caption: there is less chance that it's going to
Caption: navigate to a slide that loses
Caption: if the test is neutral that is neither
Caption: the player nor the AI win we simply just
Caption: do nothing
Caption: so
Caption: this is an AI That's initialized with
Caption: random choices but you'll be able to see
Caption: as we go forward how it works
Caption: the player is just put in the center and
Caption: we click again to make the AI move
Caption: in this case the randomly blinking
Caption: shapes promoted us to navigate to a
Caption: slide there
Caption: now a player made a mistake there the AI
Caption: has a chance to win here an optimized
Caption: model will put it on the top
Caption: but because there's an equal chance
Caption: currently for the AI to click onto the
Caption: navigate to the wrong slide it doesn't
Caption: it makes a mistake we're going to
Caption: discourage this from happening by
Caption: navigating back through every slide and
Caption: taking away one of those randomly
Caption: blinking shapes so that if it's ever in
Caption: the same position again it has less
Caption: chance to navigate to that losing slide
Caption: and then
Caption: we do it again
Caption: the AI will make a move in the top left
Caption: hand corner and the player will make
Caption: another move
Caption: this time the a made a different move
Caption: it's setting itself up right to win but
Caption: a player blocks it
Caption: player now has a chance to win so an
Caption: optimized AI with all the navigation
Caption: shapes configured correctly we try and
Caption: put it in the bottom but again it makes
Caption: a mistake so moving forward we
Caption: discourage that by taking away every
Caption: shape that leads to this state
Caption: from the PowerPoint deck
Caption: and this is a long ruling process
Caption: there is a question that I'm sure a lot
Caption: of you have been asking throughout all
Caption: of this
Caption: how many games
Caption: um
Caption: to be sure I mean it's great to say what
Caption: machine learning is not maybe break the
Caption: stigma how it can be used but why does
Caption: the fundamentals of the understanding
Caption: machine learning matter
Caption: besides the fun of knowledge for
Caption: knowledge's sake why did I go through
Caption: this whole process of constructing a way
Caption: to train a PowerPoint to go through a
Caption: machine learning algorithm
Caption: what I hope is clear by now is the
Caption: distinction between traditional control
Caption: logic and the Machine learning approach
Caption: and that's all it is an approach
Caption: the difference suggests a fundamental
Caption: change in how we conduct analysis build
Caption: Automation and program
Caption: in the other models we saw predicting a
Caption: digit based on its Darkness or randomly
Caption: guessing are examples of this
Caption: traditional logic if this then that
Caption: however machine learning if nothing else
Caption: is a tool that allows us to move past
Caption: this constrained test
Caption: it's not possible to know every then
Caption: this and it's certainly too time
Caption: consuming to label every then that
Caption: machine learning allows us to tackle
Caption: problems that we couldn't possibly know
Caption: how to tackle
Caption: machine learning is not just predicting
Caption: digits or analyzing text sentiment but
Caption: any process in which we can test score
Caption: and provide feedback
Caption: all of the advancements in machine
Caption: learning the maths the the distributed
Caption: compute are just ways that we can extend
Caption: this process of creating fancy tests
Caption: scoring it and then running it again
Caption: in cases like I said the cross entropy
Caption: loss which sounds pretty fancy but all
Caption: it is is a way of getting our list of
Caption: numbers that we predicted and the list
Caption: of numbers that we expected and doing a
Caption: calculating a score that is kind of easy
Caption: to comprehend
Caption: sometimes it's not as easy so the
Caption: researchers have to go above and beyond
Caption: to try and think about what they're even
Caption: trying to test
Caption: an example like the audio transcription
Caption: paper that we saw where they were faced
Caption: with a problem that isn't immediately
Caption: obvious what we do so they rather than
Caption: diving into let's just pump up with more
Caption: compute power it was let's take a step
Caption: back and what is it that we're even
Caption: trying to test it's the other Dynamics
Caption: correct
Caption: in a PowerPoint example
Caption: it's not
Caption: how can we somehow make some code in
Caption: PowerPoint although PowerPoint is true
Caption: and complete
Caption: um
Caption: it's a way of analyzing what we have to
Caption: work with shapes slides and animations
Caption: and how can we use those to do the
Caption: fundamental components of testing
Caption: scoring and providing feedback
Caption: by adding and subtracting shapes the
Caption: animation allows us to navigate through
Caption: States but it simply taking away and
Caption: adding shapes that allows us to provide
Caption: feedback
Caption: in the end machine learning Taps into
Caption: something that we take for granted but
Caption: applies it in a programmatic way
Caption: it's our ability to learn before knowing
Caption: so thank you
Caption: on the slides here I have uh some of the
Caption: resources that I did mention neural
Caption: networks in deep learning is the book
Caption: All Around the fundamentals of neural
Caption: networks
Caption: started using the terms AI Machining a
Caption: little bit interchangeably but as I
Caption: mentioned way at the beginning machine
Caption: learning is just one Avenue that allows
Caption: us to get through Ai and it's one of the
Caption: most popular and it's certainly useful
Caption: neural networks is another subset of
Caption: machine learning it's a particular of
Caption: interest of mine but if anyone's
Caption: interested in learning more I'd
Caption: recommend that book
Caption: on set and Frames dual objective pianos
Caption: show inscription is the paper that I
Caption: maybe flippantly was reviewing I want to
Caption: be clear that the Google lab team and
Caption: everyone that worked on that the
Caption: incredible work but it does provide a
Caption: good example of how in the real world
Caption: sometimes how we test and how we score
Caption: isn't immediately obvious
Caption: Menace the pile of matchboxes which can
Caption: learn if you want to look at this but
Caption: done in matchboxes have a go at that but
Caption: I mean they cheated right they had a
Caption: whole bunch of people working um this
Caption: was just me in a PowerPoint
Caption: which is a lot sadder than now I'm
Caption: saying it out loud
Caption: and lastly great impractical ideas
Caption: computer science PowerPoint programming
Caption: is a hoot it's a long one but if you
Caption: want to see a turing machine in
Caption: PowerPoint there's your go
Caption: if you're interested in a follow-up you
Caption: can add me on Twitter LinkedIn you can
Caption: go to the blog site that I occasionally
Caption: write
Caption: um I do have a working version of this
Caption: PowerPoint AI as you saw in the video
Caption: it's not yet optimized for playing
Caption: Tic-Tac-Toe perfectly because it takes
Caption: many many iterations of running the test
Caption: adding and subtracting the shapes and my
Caption: friends didn't find that interesting on
Caption: a Saturday night so um yeah please reach
Caption: out to me if you're interested in
Caption: versing a PowerPoint in tic-tac-toe
Caption: I lastly want to thank all of the
Caption: sponsors for DDD they're the people who
Caption: allow us me to stand up here and talk
Caption: about something that I have no right to
Caption: be uh talking about a PowerPoint Ai and
Caption: also thank you to all the volunteers who
Caption: work up very early today to get this all
Caption: working
Caption: thank you
Caption: I think we have time for some questions
Caption: yeah
Caption: I think we've got a question there yeah
Caption: oh thanks so you said machine learning
Caption: is one of the ways to do AI what are the
Caption: ways yeah AI is like about as broad as
Caption: term as you can get some people consider
Caption: things like statistical models and
Caption: everything to be part of AI so that's
Caption: not something that uses an iterative
Caption: approach
Caption: um but you know things like probability
Caption: tests and t-tests other people uh
Caption: natural language processing is a really
Caption: interesting example of AI that isn't
Caption: machine learning because there's a whole
Caption: bunch of still maths linear algebra and
Caption: stuff but they don't do the iterative
Caption: approach they just do like Vector
Caption: multiplication and stuff like that
Caption: that's simplifying it a lot but there
Caption: are yeah those are some of the examples
Caption: next question
Caption: um I was pretty impressed with what
Caption: we've seen today but I just wanted to
Caption: ask what's next next oh well I mean go
Caption: is one of the most complicated games you
Caption: can play Maybe
Caption: no
Caption: um I don't know I mean to be honest this
Caption: is just a fun example maybe I've spent
Caption: too much time on it but it was more of
Caption: an exploration into
Caption: how fundamental machine learning
Caption: actually is I'm not sure I'd do
Caption: something like this again
Caption: yeah unless you sat me down in a torture
Caption: room but um I can't stress enough how
Caption: many hours it was to form that board
Caption: um but yeah I'm always Keen in
Caption: investigating these sort of weird
Caption: approaches so
Caption: anyone else lucky last question guys
Caption: anybody
Caption: wonderful oh oh we've got another one
Caption: you know I'll talk about this for hours
Caption: oh yeah um yeah I'll ask another
Caption: question so I was just curious with the
Caption: um PowerPoints I never thought of it but
Caption: um did you so there's no code you just
Caption: literally have a PowerPoint that just
Caption: click through it yeah yeah yeah
Caption: someone was manually doing the um like
Caption: punishments and rewards yeah wow okay
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: like I said there was macros involved to
Caption: like insert the slides um like I'm not
Caption: gonna copy and paste one 1830 slides
Caption: um but yeah those those macros weren't
Caption: used for the actual training of it
Caption: because that kind of defeats the purpose
Caption: this would be
Caption: easy to do it in VBA or something like
Caption: that but it wouldn't it defeat the
Caption: purpose of the whole exercise I think
Caption: personally I mean maybe I'm just
Caption: sadistic but yeah
Caption: thank you so
Caption: thank you very much
Caption: that's it
Caption: all right guys in here in about 10
Caption: minutes we're gonna have George coldham
Caption: and swen Lee
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh okay you can you can
Caption: see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends I'm Scott hansman and I was
Caption: told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: foreign
Caption: what do you want
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: information
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you got
Caption: it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh Gap is almost
Caption: ready uh we just need
Caption: three more days we need it ASAP okay
Caption: team what's the status on the app we're
Caption: good to go accept our login experience
Caption: is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: flawlessly because because I don't want
Caption: to lose one single customer I hear you
Caption: so let's use off zero off what now off
Caption: zero it's an identity platform fast easy
Caption: logins just what the boss wants can we
Caption: make our own authentication Service come
Caption: on the Ultimate key master you know we
Caption: don't have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use oh Sarah can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up I will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep I think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it I cut a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what I want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's Stephen
Caption: what's up Stephen
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: um okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: Scott hansman and I was told to give you
Caption: a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our movies
Caption: water to join Scott henselman
Caption: what do you want
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a Fearless hunger for
Caption: Success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using AI to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates
Caption: get you to just quieten down for me I
Caption: will close that back door just in a
Caption: moment
Caption: right now we have two wonderful
Caption: individuals
Caption: to my left I have swen it is swen's
Caption: first time presenting so please give her
Caption: a warm welcome
Caption: now Swan is a final year student
Caption: studying a Bachelor of Computer Science
Caption: with a major in cyber security she's
Caption: also a student ambassador for the School
Caption: of Science at ECU and he's also doing an
Caption: internship at retrospect Labs damn girl
Caption: you're busy
Caption: um George you're a tech geek 20 years uh
Caption: by the looks of things you're also a
Caption: gamer at night yes love it on that note
Caption: I'm gonna hand it over so I don't talk
Caption: too much good luck thank you thank you
Caption: all right
Caption: everyone can hear me fine
Caption: cool man I know so many of you in the
Caption: room it feels like a family reunion this
Caption: is awesome so thank you for coming to
Caption: the talk with me and Swan uh before we
Caption: get started I want to say thank you to
Caption: all of our sponsors because without the
Caption: sponsors we don't have this amazing day
Caption: I'm not sure if any of you have been
Caption: involved with running conferences before
Caption: but without sponsors then they're
Caption: impossible and like to get a conference
Caption: like this for 60 bucks is just like it's
Caption: unheard of so that's really cool so
Caption: thank you very much to the sponsors
Caption: so uh this is the agenda we will be
Caption: going over today what can go wrong which
Caption: may lead to financial loss what we can
Caption: do to reduce the risk and a short wrap
Caption: up with the key takeaways from today's
Caption: talk
Caption: ah sorry forgot to introduce myself my
Caption: name is Sun Lee uh like she said I am a
Caption: final year cyber security student at
Caption: edif Cohen University I am also a mini
Caption: mini vlogger on Instagram during my free
Caption: time and I play a little bit of ping
Caption: pong when I'm not rushing my assignments
Caption: and I can play a few instruments like
Caption: the piano the electron the guitar but
Caption: not all at once so over to you George
Caption: thank you so uh for those that don't
Caption: know me I am a Cloud solution architect
Caption: at Microsoft in the cyber security I do
Caption: a lot of stuff with the Defenders so if
Caption: you've heard of the defender products
Caption: then you know what I do I play games I
Caption: play lots of Rocket League I'm a champ
Caption: one but I should be you know a grand
Caption: champ and uh I'm also my dad I've got
Caption: two little kids and they like to share
Caption: in case you've heard my sexy voice
Caption: um I don't normally have such a deep
Caption: voice but yeah so that's us
Caption: so I've got to fess up you know it's a
Caption: bit of a click bait title with the um
Caption: with the talk so thank you for voting Us
Caption: in
Caption: um we we do have like a serious topic to
Caption: talk about
Caption: um and uh we'll we'll get into it right
Caption: now but you know so how can
Caption: you lose your money and what can go
Caption: wrong
Caption: so
Caption: I was trying to put the talk together
Caption: I've got swen uh who's our you know my
Caption: protege and and wants to learn how to
Caption: talk at conferences so what's a nice
Caption: topical generic subject we can speak
Caption: about in order to educate and you know
Caption: not be too deep and intimidating I'm
Caption: like well let's talk about Sim swapping
Caption: has anyone heard of sim swapping
Caption: manual
Caption: all right so just imagine you're holding
Caption: your phone scrolling through Tick Tock
Caption: and sitting there waiting for the bus or
Caption: whatever and then all of a sudden your
Caption: data stops and then you look at the top
Caption: and instead of it saying Optus or
Caption: Telstra or Vodafone it says SOS
Caption: that's the experience you'll receive
Caption: when you've been Sim swapped essentially
Caption: what a Sim swap is is someone
Caption: fraudulently pretends to be you and
Caption: steals your phone number
Caption: all right so why do they do that most
Caption: banks are pretty sucky with their
Caption: security sorry Banks and specially
Caption: Bankwest being a sponsor but like you
Caption: know your MFA
Caption: normally is SMS with a bank so if you
Caption: own the phone number then they can
Caption: pretty much say that they're you verify
Caption: money transfers
Caption: um
Caption: the other reason why Sim swaps can be
Caption: somewhat effective is especially on a
Caption: prepaid service you don't need a lot of
Caption: information to do a Sim swap
Caption: so I thought I'd do a Sim swap on myself
Caption: I did it with a prepaid that I
Caption: registered and then I got another
Caption: prepaid sim I'm not going to do it with
Caption: my details but um basically you can see
Caption: here this is the number
Caption: and I needed to know these two things
Caption: right so these can be found reasonably
Caption: easy like if a hacker was doing this
Caption: you'd assume that they've already
Caption: compromised you in some way probably
Caption: I've got your email box there's like a
Caption: statistic like 98.9 of gmails do not
Caption: have two-factor authentication turned on
Caption: them right and
Caption: there's an odds odds are a lot of people
Caption: are quite sucky with their passwords and
Caption: reuse passwords and we'll talk about
Caption: that in a little while but um so to do a
Caption: Sim swap you need to know a phone number
Caption: and you need to know the provider
Caption: and then all you need to do is have an
Caption: ID type so for
Caption: circles.life you need to have either a
Caption: driver's license a Medicare card or a
Caption: passport number but they don't actually
Caption: verify that you just need to know the
Caption: number
Caption: right so there's my license number
Caption: but you know because it's so easy I'm
Caption: not going to give it to you there's my
Caption: first name my middle name shown on my
Caption: license my last name
Caption: then you need the date of birth
Caption: but if you've got the license number
Caption: you've probably got the date of birth
Caption: right like an attacker is going to be
Caption: prepared they're not going to be like
Caption: some schmuck like me trying to simulate
Caption: it for your benefit so you know and you
Caption: need the email but once you've got that
Caption: like to me that's not a very high bar if
Caption: you're able to compromise someone's
Caption: email
Caption: and then you verify it with a code sent
Caption: to the email it's blurrier than I
Caption: thought it would be sorry
Caption: um but then that initiates the um the
Caption: Sim swap
Caption: so that was the text I got
Caption: um that was the the validation of the ID
Caption: but you saw that was all of the
Caption: information I gave them so you don't
Caption: need the physical ID you just need the
Caption: information and I know that like in the
Caption: past when I've traveled say overseas
Caption: I've um
Caption: taken a scan of important documents just
Caption: so I don't lose it if in case you know I
Caption: lose it I can prove who I am so I
Caption: haven't deleted that I don't know how
Caption: long people have had the same mailbox
Caption: but I've had some for 15 years and
Caption: that's got a lot of pii in it and if I
Caption: lost access then I'll lose it
Caption: so
Caption: so you may ask why you should care about
Caption: this and what does all of this have to
Caption: do with you as a consumer well as
Caption: consumers we need to protect ourselves
Caption: against
Caption: hackers
Caption: what that was meant to be humorous but
Caption: never mind
Caption: so next up we are going to talk about
Caption: potential attack vectors which may lead
Caption: to account compromise
Caption: there are many websites that have been
Caption: compromised tryhand Publishers a site
Caption: you can use to see which one of your
Caption: accounts have been compromised if they
Caption: are so this is a very popular website
Caption: called have I been pawned we actually
Caption: use this at the Cohen University for our
Caption: cyber security workshops as well and
Caption: just simply key in your sorry just
Caption: simply key in your email address or your
Caption: phone number and this website tells you
Caption: whether or not it has been compromised
Caption: and how many instances that has happened
Caption: so this website keeps a database of
Caption: accounts with their credentials
Caption: compromised as you can see here there
Caption: are
Caption: 626 websites hacked 11 billion accounts
Caption: breached and
Caption: I don't know what those two are but yeah
Caption: password reuse so even if you secure the
Caption: data well the user might just give it
Caption: away with poor password hygiene
Caption: so can we have a show of hands of how
Caption: many people here we use the same
Caption: password across multiple sites
Caption: ah ah
Caption: wait I want to know who those are I want
Caption: to hack you oh wait sorry about that uh
Caption: so anyway
Caption: according to this website dataprod.net
Caption: on average the same password is used to
Caption: access five different accounts which
Caption: like I said I wanted to hack you guys so
Caption: if you could just write down your
Caption: credentials and put it over here I would
Caption: very much appreciate that
Caption: I'm sure this has been enforced in a lot
Caption: of account logins especially in
Caption: organizations multi-factor
Caption: authentication or MFA when you develop
Caption: an application encourage or enforce your
Caption: users to register for multi-factor
Caption: Authentication
Caption: ideally you do not build your own
Caption: authentication process but leverage an
Caption: authentication provider that manages the
Caption: user accounts securely and provides a
Caption: secure authentication process with
Caption: two-factor Authentication
Caption: hyperscalers all allow for it for
Caption: example Azure and other dedicated
Caption: providers providers for authentication
Caption: like r0 who has their Booth right
Caption: outside or Microsoft authenticator and
Caption: so on
Caption: just don't use SMS for MFA how because
Caption: we've already proven that since I've
Caption: been kind of a sucky method right
Caption: so uh dependency hell uh when you write
Caption: software you don't write everything from
Caption: Star we just said don't use don't roll
Caption: your own authentication like that's a a
Caption: rule that people hopefully all follow
Caption: but at the same time you know if you've
Caption: got to log files you don't want to write
Caption: your own logging solution there's
Caption: logging Solutions out there there's this
Caption: awesome one called log4j people may have
Caption: heard of it
Caption: um then there's you know maybe you want
Caption: to upload files to a website or a web
Caption: server collect documents you use a
Caption: library or you use a dependency but the
Caption: problem is
Caption: when you use it
Caption: you don't know what's in that Library it
Caption: can be like a real mess right so this is
Caption: an uh a comic
Caption: um if you go find it you'll see like
Caption: there's this this piece of string from
Caption: this chaos
Caption: all the way you know so it looks nice
Caption: and harmless here
Caption: you trust it because it does what you
Caption: need it to do but it's a mess
Caption: all right so who wrote it what checks
Caption: have they done is it safe and secure or
Caption: are they you know gonna give your data
Caption: away
Caption: oh look look for Jay so if you don't
Caption: know what log 4J was it was like the
Caption: most fun Christmas present uh security
Caption: team was ever given
Caption: because basically there was a
Caption: vulnerability which anyone could exploit
Caption: by using a URL from memory
Caption: um and then
Caption: they patched it and the patch didn't
Caption: work so they went through all this
Caption: trouble to patch it and it didn't work
Caption: so then they had to patch it again but
Caption: then that didn't work so they had to
Caption: patch it again and they fixed the
Caption: problem by actually removing the feature
Caption: so it was good time and like it was it's
Caption: been used in so many places that it was
Caption: um a real nightmare and the other
Caption: example we've got for this is the tiny
Caption: file manager which I'd never heard of I
Caption: actually searched through cve
Caption: vulnerabilities looking for examples
Caption: that were pretty straightforward this
Caption: package allows you to upload files in a
Caption: website right and this one here if you
Caption: upload a file and that file has the
Caption: right file name you can actually put
Caption: code in the file name and it would
Caption: execute the code so it um it seemed like
Caption: a pretty simple one to execute if you
Caption: knew that it was vulnerable so you know
Caption: you just want to be able to upload files
Caption: you don't care how it does it but maybe
Caption: you need to
Caption: okay let's talk about storing customer
Caption: data
Caption: authentication we need to ensure that
Caption: the user is the person they say they are
Caption: by authentication this means that only
Caption: an application is allowed to access
Caption: certain data for example when we have a
Caption: server on the back end that manages
Caption: multiple websites and we only want
Caption: website a to be allowed to accept to
Caption: authenticate database B
Caption: Access Control
Caption: that means to check if a user is allowed
Caption: to access an application or a database
Caption: that he or she is trying to access for
Caption: instance a human resource manager of a
Caption: company is allowed to access a database
Caption: that contains employees information but
Caption: an IT admin does not this will also
Caption: prevent Hackers from easily obtaining a
Caption: company's sensitive information
Caption: so this also applies if you're writing
Caption: an application you can have a service
Caption: principle which is like a user account
Caption: for the application itself you can
Caption: assign only the permissions that it's
Caption: needed so that it can only authenticate
Caption: against the services it needs to
Caption: authenticate and then once it's
Caption: authenticated it can only access the
Caption: data or services that it needs to access
Caption: so it works equally the same with a
Caption: human or with an application
Caption: and then we've got two more parts around
Caption: the storing we're looking at the
Caption: encrypting data when it's at rest and
Caption: when it's that Transit so just assuming
Caption: you um your your service is compromised
Caption: and they are able to steal that data if
Caption: it's encrypted at rest uh and you know
Caption: you haven't done something silly like
Caption: put your encryption key in your code
Caption: um then odds are they're not going to be
Caption: able to do much with that blob of data
Caption: like a modern encryption system it's
Caption: such that it can't be easily cracked
Caption: even if you're you know leveraging the
Caption: power of a nation state
Caption: and then also in transit when you're
Caption: sending data between Network Services or
Caption: you know a modern web service would have
Caption: multiple components sending the data
Caption: between those components you want to
Caption: make sure you're using an encrypted
Caption: Channel because especially if you're
Caption: using
Caption: um you know
Caption: cheap providers or trying to rationalize
Caption: across multiple providers
Caption: sending that data might go over the
Caption: public internet or I might go over
Caption: shared channels so if you have your
Caption: encryption you're maintaining privacy
Caption: between your different endpoints so it's
Caption: it's super important to make sure you're
Caption: using encryption
Caption: so
Caption: we've got some key takeaways
Caption: passwords are terrible
Caption: if you can move away from passwords
Caption: probably a bit hard if you're just
Caption: writing a web app to you know do your
Caption: fantasy football or something but you
Caption: still could you know not to show
Caption: Microsoft but I work there and you know
Caption: my authenticator allows you to do
Caption: password less and I know that other
Caption: authentication providers allow you to do
Caption: password like through a push
Caption: notification so then your device
Caption: becomes your password
Caption: and it doesn't have to be tied to your
Caption: phone number which is good
Caption: second software dependencies you rely on
Caption: might be your undoing so please be sure
Caption: that your dependencies that your or your
Caption: your software libraries that you're
Caption: using but they're safe and you've got
Caption: some sort of process to make sure that
Caption: they stay updated you know
Caption: you can't write everything you have to
Caption: rely on it but you also need to have a
Caption: process to make sure that it stays safe
Caption: and lastly make sure you store your data
Caption: securely because
Caption: um you know that's what your customers
Caption: trust you to do
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: alrighty guys first of all that was
Caption: fantastic we do have some time for
Caption: questions so if you want to pop your
Caption: hands up I'll come around with the
Caption: microphone and you can feel really cool
Caption: like me and talking to it and ask a
Caption: question
Caption: come on guys
Caption: you are my man
Caption: thanks guys so just quick question on um
Caption: password so what if he's out of that
Caption: like uses like Google to log in is that
Caption: better than passwords oh yeah
Caption: yeah like a hyperscaler is going to do a
Caption: much better job than yourself
Caption: or you know even if you're leveraging
Caption: like a PHP library or something like
Caption: that just just seeing if you can
Caption: Outsource to a company that is doing
Caption: millions of logins a day or a second or
Caption: whatever then they're going to have a
Caption: lot more better protection
Caption: I'm going to Chuck a question in should
Caption: I go and put my email address in that
Caption: have I done porn yes like seriously I
Caption: should probably do that between yeah
Caption: yeah okay cool we learn something new
Caption: every day
Caption: I just wanted to ask what is your
Caption: opinion on authentication tokens or the
Caption: ones that do the generation numbers that
Caption: some companies give you
Caption: oh like an RSA token yeah yeah generally
Caption: pretty safe I mean like because you need
Caption: to have registered on the device that
Caption: you trust whether it's your little token
Caption: or if it's the authenticator app on your
Caption: phone
Caption: um so there's only one source of that
Caption: six digit number to log in
Caption: right so when you lose your phone it's a
Caption: pain in the you know because you
Caption: sometimes have a whole series of codes
Caption: that you can use as one-time logins to
Caption: prove you are who you are but even if
Caption: someone does a Sim swap they're not
Caption: stealing all the data on your phone so
Caption: if you've got like the Google
Caption: Authenticator Microsoft authenticator
Caption: LastPass authenticator twilio
Caption: authenticator like there's
Caption: authenticators everywhere if you're
Caption: using just one of those then that is the
Caption: source of truth even if someone steals
Caption: your password good let them
Caption: duck there was one here
Caption: just curious uh you recommended we try
Caption: to use different passwords for different
Caption: platforms
Caption: um I do know we have some free open
Caption: password manager
Caption: two do you recommend people to use it if
Caption: so what kind of tools do you use
Caption: personally except the kitchen like
Caption: iPhone Muse so yeah
Caption: do you use one uh personally I do not
Caption: but I have my organization people
Caption: sitting over there and they use Bill
Caption: Warden as their password manager I hope
Caption: they don't kill me when I get off the
Caption: stage
Caption: uh I don't want to read that report
Caption: um I use LastPass and
Caption: um
Caption: LastPass but that one's a paid one but
Caption: I'm lucky because I became a customer
Caption: like 2012 so I knew still pay 12 us a
Caption: year for it and
Caption: the other one which is on the have I
Caption: been owned past uh key pass no
Caption: one password thank you yes
Caption: and I also use my phone but it syncs
Caption: across yeah
Caption: and so when I don't think you'll get in
Caption: trouble you can hack me later on from
Caption: what I've worked out we might make it up
Caption: we'll talk about this later
Caption: yeah all right thanks for that um I was
Caption: going to ask about password managers as
Caption: well so some of them are offering the
Caption: MFA functionality in there as well do
Caption: you think that's a good idea having the
Caption: password and the MFA yes like like one
Caption: password for example yes and then you
Caption: mentioned LastPass but even the password
Caption: managers are getting compromised yes
Caption: like they had a recent issue in the dev
Caption: environment I think and I don't know
Caption: what do you what's your take on all that
Caption: so LastPass was compromised only a week
Caption: or two ago like their servers got done
Caption: and I'm completely comfortable with that
Caption: because the way LastPass works is they
Caption: just get an encrypted blob of data and
Caption: your master password is the key to
Caption: decrypt that blob of data so
Caption: and you know if they can guess their
Caption: password and and that's not like a
Caption: random generated one because I have to
Caption: type it from memory
Caption: um but it's still you know almost 20
Caption: characters long so
Caption: I feel good about that um I would feel
Caption: bad if there was like poorly written
Caption: code which meant they could bypass the
Caption: encryption key or do it another way then
Caption: I'd feel really sucky about it um having
Caption: um the MFA in the same solution as the
Caption: password manager I'm fine with because
Caption: my password manager I can log in on like
Caption: I don't know how many devices but the
Caption: MFA still stays on that same device and
Caption: it's like that single source of Truth
Caption: still so if you know you buy a new phone
Caption: you need to transfer that MFA from one
Caption: to the other
Caption: um
Caption: so yeah it's pretty good
Caption: these guys have killed
Caption: killed it and when I look forward to
Caption: seeing you next year too
Caption: all right guys we do have another
Caption: session in here I have just lost my
Caption: notes to give me two secs and I'll let
Caption: you know who it is
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: all right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh okay you can you can
Caption: see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends um Scott Hanson and I was
Caption: told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh cup is almost
Caption: ready uh we just need
Caption: three more days we need it ASAP okay
Caption: team what's the status on the app we're
Caption: good to go accept our login experience
Caption: is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the Hacker's house
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because I don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer I hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication Service come on the
Caption: ultimate keymaster you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use oh Siri can do that yeah but
Caption: it needs to be secure we can't have our
Caption: app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up I will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep hey
Caption: bigger customers are gonna love it I cut
Caption: a real app now folks
Caption: you know what I want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's Stephen
Caption: what's up Stephen
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: all right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: um okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: Scott Hanselman and I was told to give
Caption: you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our puppies
Caption: foreign
Caption: what do you want
Caption: oh my chocolate
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a Fearless hunger for
Caption: Success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using AI to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a Children's
Caption: Hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at Insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young Brothers
Caption: to a Fortune 500 company offering I.T
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be now is
Caption: the time to do big things together now
Caption: is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: a bit of an intro so Josh is here with
Caption: us today he's a distinguished
Caption: technologist at cantino he's also a
Caption: published author which I think is bloody
Caption: Wicked he's generally
Caption: he is generally referred to at cantino
Caption: as the break glass in case of emergency
Caption: made human
Caption: he works with businesses all over
Caption: Australia helping them to digitally
Caption: transform he will also be taking some
Caption: questions and from what I hear that are
Caption: signing of the book could be a
Caption: possibility guys so Josh are we good
Caption: hopefully let's give it a red hot coat
Caption: if you can use that one so we can all
Caption: hear you I mean people can probably hear
Caption: me oh God people can probably hear me
Caption: anyway so I'm generally loud all right
Caption: serverless testing uh local considered
Caption: harmful so people may have heard me
Caption: speak before in which case you might
Caption: have presumed this warning was coming
Caption: there's going to be a lot of strong
Caption: opinions that hopefully loosely held
Caption: your mileage may vary I'm not saying I
Caption: have all the answers just most of them
Caption: so you know we'll have to see how that
Caption: goes right
Caption: all right the hero slasher villain uh
Caption: for our story today it's a friend of
Caption: mine called Richards who I worked with
Caption: in the UK
Caption: um he's drunk the cloud native Kool-Aid
Caption: as you can see
Caption: um that is a suit he actually owns
Caption: um so when I talk about Cloud native
Caption: I'm not meaning this Unholy Cambrian
Caption: explosion of things that the cncf has
Caption: really it's building for the cloud not
Caption: just on the cloud right that can mean
Caption: kubernetes but I argue in most cases it
Caption: probably not
Caption: but okay so
Caption: back to Richard and we're gonna we're
Caption: gonna start and I always try and start
Caption: this way so when people get bored of me
Caption: speaking hopefully they've got the
Caption: takeaways to start so we're going to
Caption: start with the three key takeaways
Caption: the first is that the testing pyramid
Caption: that we've all held dear to our hearts
Caption: for many many years is a service
Caption: anti-pattern in reality
Caption: um hopefully some of these are
Caption: contentious I'm hoping to you know piss
Caption: people off as we go
Caption: um again it makes it more fun
Caption: um second emulating the cloud is a
Caption: recipe for disappointment I will be
Caption: ragging on local stack for about half
Caption: this talk maybe not half but you know
Caption: you've got to go with me on this and
Caption: hopefully I can convince you to throw it
Caption: in the bin tomorrow and the last is
Caption: testing doesn't stop when code hits
Caption: production
Caption: um again hopefully people agree with me
Caption: on this or they don't either way
Caption: hopefully you agree with me by the end
Caption: um so there's already an intro on me so
Caption: I'll go very very quick
Caption: um so yeah we're doing this technology
Caption: that container which is a ridiculous
Caption: title
Caption: um I work with Enterprises I've done
Caption: world first service architecture on AWS
Caption: I've done mainframes I've done machine
Caption: learning
Caption: um I am a speaker and I do have a few
Caption: copies to give away I can sign them if
Caption: you want but I feel really weird doing
Caption: it
Caption: um I'm Dave dos Ambassador hashing
Caption: Ambassador you know all the kind of
Caption: stuff I'm a professional lab mouth
Caption: um so I'm going to talk about functional
Caption: testing today when I say testing that's
Caption: what most people think and there are so
Caption: many other things you can and should be
Caption: testing but I have 45 minutes so I'm
Caption: going to focus or try anyway I generally
Caption: add lib a lot so we'll see how this goes
Caption: uh why do we test and I just realize I
Caption: have that slide twice why do we test
Caption: is it to prevent bugs
Caption: yes and no
Caption: um kind of
Caption: I'm gonna apologize for this but I'm
Caption: going to go a little bit of complexity
Caption: Theory
Caption: um
Caption: so when we build systems they are
Caption: complex adaptive systems
Caption: it's a very uh very long way of saying
Caption: when we make changes we don't really
Caption: know what's going to happen we have
Caption: ideas we have theories but we can't know
Caption: what's going to happen
Caption: and if you don't believe me or this is
Caption: kind of new I think we've all been
Caption: through this you know you're working on
Caption: something you know you get to daily
Caption: stand-up the next day and yeah no I
Caption: found something new it's kind of the
Caption: it's the problem in the fun of software
Caption: development it's emergent you don't know
Caption: what you're doing until you do it which
Caption: is why estimating another one of my uh
Caption: pain points is pointless and that's
Caption: probably also going to piss some people
Caption: off which is fantastic
Caption: going from complexity Theory
Caption: um
Caption: so behaviors of systems of complex
Caption: adapter systems are emergent property
Caption: you can try and control them but
Caption: effectively they happen not 100 by
Caption: chance but just because you build
Caption: something doesn't mean you know what
Caption: it's going to do
Caption: this also means that unintended
Caption: behaviors are emergent property because
Caption: you don't know what's going to happen
Caption: which that means that bugs an emergent
Caption: property because bugs is effectively
Caption: just a synonym for unintended behaviors
Caption: the bugs are inevitable
Caption: um you're really not going to get around
Caption: them
Caption: so if testing isn't about the you know
Caption: preventing bugs in their entirety what
Caption: what are you actually trying to achieve
Caption: really for me it's this that the value
Caption: of the release you're trying to do the
Caption: value of the change you're trying to do
Caption: is greater than the risk of doing the
Caption: change
Caption: that's all you're trying to really do
Caption: you're trying to go actually putting
Caption: this change of production is more
Caption: valuable than the potential risk impact
Caption: you can't be sure about this it's all
Caption: about confidence you can have to be 100
Caption: confidence even with an ego as big as
Caption: mine I can never be 100 confident that
Caption: I've got it right
Caption: um but really what would fundamentally
Caption: what we're trying to do is how cheaply
Caption: can you be confident or sufficiently
Caption: confident that the value of the release
Caption: is more than the risk and obviously risk
Caption: can take many different factors in terms
Caption: of you break production or unintended or
Caption: the you know there's all the damage that
Caption: comes from that in terms of Financial
Caption: and reputational and maybe you get
Caption: smarts across the head because you've
Caption: released so many bugs into production
Caption: there's lots of different kinds of risk
Caption: in there
Caption: again just stepping back to complexity
Caption: Theory one last time I promise I'll move
Caption: on
Caption: um when you look at complex area and
Caption: then you get tesserin are these enabling
Caption: constraints they allow us to preserve
Caption: certain behaviors of the system but
Caption: they're not guaranteed to exercise the
Caption: entirety of the system so you're not
Caption: going to cover everything but you're
Caption: going to cover a lot
Caption: Google very eloquently put it uh like
Caption: this
Caption: um the Beyonce rule if you liked it you
Caption: should have put a CI test on it Google
Caption: have taken this idea to the extreme with
Caption: the idea that anyone in the business can
Caption: make pretty much any change to any
Caption: system that they want
Caption: so upgrading a package take the log4j
Caption: thing that happened right Google can
Caption: update that in their one giant monorepo
Caption: they are insane
Caption: um but that can be done by security and
Caption: if your system breaks it is your fault
Caption: not theirs
Caption: so it's changing with accountability
Caption: lies from the person that made the
Caption: change the person that owns the system
Caption: but fundamentally Google has probably
Caption: second to non-testing culture and it
Caption: enables a lot of the stuff that they do
Caption: again
Caption: when we build a system we have a mental
Caption: model of how we think the system works
Caption: and we have a software model which is
Caption: how the system actually works and
Caption: testing is an opportunity to refine our
Caption: mental to try and bring it closer to the
Caption: software model and the closer you are
Caption: the better the quicker you can develop
Caption: the less bugs you're going to introduce
Caption: this is kind of the basis around you
Caption: know when you're on board onto a new
Caption: team you have to understand what's going
Caption: on right
Caption: so as you know you have to build these
Caption: mental models over time which is why you
Caption: get the guys who've worked on the system
Caption: for 20 years seem to know everything
Caption: backwards and forwards and the guy's
Caption: been there two months it's like what the
Caption: hell is going on
Caption: really common refrain that I see when
Caption: people start on the serverless bit is
Caption: they find that testing just feels really
Caption: hard
Caption: it feels really hard for them to do
Caption: they're like it doesn't work the way it
Caption: used to
Caption: um you know I'm starting to do a whole
Caption: bunch of different things it's not
Caption: really working like all of a sudden I
Caption: need Docker compose to run like 10
Caption: containers on my laptop and it's set on
Caption: fire that kind of stuff that you see
Caption: happening around the track right
Caption: the fundamental problems that although
Caption: serverless you know Lambda functions and
Caption: Cloud run and visual functions all that
Caption: wonderful stuff although there is
Caption: technology Service as a whole is
Caption: actually a mindset it's not just about
Caption: moving the technology it's a new
Caption: paradigm that comes with new ways of
Caption: working if you try and apply all the
Caption: ways you used to do things in like a
Caption: monolithic on-premise environment to a
Caption: serverless environment you can have a
Caption: bad time which is what a lot of people
Caption: do
Caption: if you try and do Cloud native
Caption: development with a pre-cloud testing
Caption: approach local Dev sub is hellish you
Caption: know the working with some Enterprises
Caption: like oh someone's onboarding cool all
Caption: right well it might have the laptops out
Caption: ready to go in two weeks it's like
Caption: that's a lot of time I've worked on
Caption: teams where we had people joining
Caption: pushing to production within an hour of
Caption: joining if you get this stuff right you
Caption: can move so fast testing across multiple
Caption: Services is brittle
Caption: um this is something people find when
Caption: they go to microservices like oh my God
Caption: what what is this how do I get the same
Caption: level of confidence and really comes
Caption: down to the tests they write are either
Caption: really hard they're hard to be impactful
Caption: because either they're very brittle and
Caption: really hard to work with or they're kind
Caption: of tortological tests are really not
Caption: testing anything at all and they kind of
Caption: end up in this really weird space where
Caption: they're like I don't have any confidence
Caption: that my system even works when I make a
Caption: change
Caption: and coming back to this serverless as a
Caption: mindset piece there's kind of Three core
Caption: drivers that led to it and they all have
Caption: impacts on the way you test
Caption: um
Caption: so these are kind of wider macroeconomic
Caption: things but really this is what the cloud
Caption: to a large degree has brought to it and
Caption: businesses so it historically and
Caption: unfortunately still in some places seen
Caption: as a cost center
Caption: um you don't want it to be you want to
Caption: see The Innovation Center
Caption: um with that comes a very different
Caption: level of expectation you are expected to
Caption: produce value not maintain costs ideally
Caption: um generally we're moving to model lists
Caption: the microservices if you're going down a
Caption: serverless path you're going to end up
Caption: doing microservices that kind of is no
Caption: way about it and you know if you're
Caption: deploying one Lambda it's God that does
Caption: everything
Caption: um think again
Caption: um
Caption: and one of the more interesting bits
Caption: especially compared to a on-premise
Caption: world that used to be long lead times oh
Caption: I need a new server setting up okay the
Caption: best case is maybe it goes to the server
Caption: team that goes and sets something up the
Caption: worst case is oh we were out of capacity
Caption: we're going to go find a server come
Caption: back in three months we might have
Caption: something for you right
Caption: it's
Caption: really different nowadays and just on
Caption: that Innovation set the point because if
Caption: people know me they know I'd never shut
Caption: up about the door metrics and I've
Caption: managed to find a way to fit them in
Caption: again
Caption: there so the reality is that nowadays we
Caption: actually have some statistically
Caption: verified ways of looking at engineering
Caption: performance and it is not velocity
Caption: um the idea is you should be able to
Caption: deliver change frequently routinely you
Caption: don't break things very often and when
Caption: you do break things it's quick to fix
Caption: now a lot of the time people come back
Caption: and go well okay that's all right for
Caption: the digital natives the Googles whatever
Caption: blah blah
Caption: the reality is nowadays it's 26 percent
Caption: of businesses one in four from the
Caption: survey respondents so obviously there's
Caption: going to be a bias there but you can
Caption: even see over time 7 to 20 26. this is
Caption: not about digital natives anymore this
Caption: is about table Stakes
Caption: if you can't do this
Caption: um you're really going to run into stuff
Caption: if you're not moving in this direction
Caption: you're really going to start to run into
Caption: problems all of a sudden the business
Caption: can be like well our competitors
Caption: innovating so much faster than us it go
Caption: faster we've done safe now you can go
Caption: faster right and we've added more scrum
Caption: Masters we're going to go faster
Caption: not how it works at all
Caption: um so now on the monolith versus
Caption: microservice it's about
Caption: the the way it used to be
Caption: um was used to have a simple arrangement
Caption: of complex objects you had virtual
Caption: machines that did a hell of a lot and
Caption: not that many of them
Caption: where it's kind of gone to now
Caption: especially in service applications is
Caption: it's a complex arrangement of simple
Caption: objects everything is easy to read is
Caption: about in isolation but instead the
Caption: complexity is actually moved from within
Caption: the service to the Integrations between
Caption: services
Caption: so now when you're trying to test the
Caption: whole kit and caboodle on a monolith and
Caption: then you try and do the same in a Lambda
Caption: function you're not going to have a good
Caption: time because what you're trying to do is
Caption: get to the heart of the complexity and
Caption: the complexities actually moved where it
Caption: is
Caption: the test pyramids everyone's familiar
Caption: surely
Caption: um
Caption: so this doesn't this really starts to
Caption: not apply
Caption: anymore
Caption: because really a lot of that complexity
Caption: that we used to kind of capture within
Caption: the unit testing start to move to
Caption: integration testing
Caption: Spotify came up with this I
Caption: it's better I mean all models um all
Caption: models are wrong some are useful it you
Caption: know it starts to actually point to the
Caption: fact that actually integration testing
Caption: unfortunately because there are caveats
Caption: on speed
Caption: um it's starting to get the more
Caption: important part to do
Caption: and really when you look at this there
Caption: are conversations we had about how
Caption: complex what are you actually trying to
Caption: achieve and this will speak to kind of
Caption: the years I've spent working on AWS
Caption: platforms when you talk about this
Caption: complex we look at Lambda functions
Caption: there are kind of two general types I
Caption: see there is address Lambda is glue
Caption: because AWS haven't done something so
Caption: you write a Lambda function to do it for
Caption: them
Caption: um which is you know all the time and
Caption: really at this point you're probably
Caption: gonna have all integration tests and
Caption: very little implementation detail tests
Caption: because
Caption: your implementation detail really
Caption: doesn't mean anything anymore because if
Caption: you take that code out of AWS it's
Caption: useless
Caption: so what you know you don't have this
Caption: nice pure domain you're trying to look
Caption: after it's about like well actually all
Caption: I'm trying to do is Stitch to radio
Caption: Services together there is nothing
Caption: reusable here so really all I need to do
Caption: is integrate against AWS Services it's
Caption: not really point trying to configure it
Caption: so you can test something locally
Caption: because what what is the point and I'll
Caption: get into more about how you can kind of
Caption: test in AWS a little bit more natively
Caption: as we go along
Caption: the kind of more interesting one
Caption: personally is with the main logic we're
Caption: actually trying to build like a system
Caption: of some form that Services users not
Caption: just makes AWS go quicker
Caption: um and at this point you do end up with
Caption: a mix of integration implementation
Caption: detail
Caption: one of the core things to do when you're
Caption: doing serverless development is all the
Caption: side effects now if there's any
Caption: functional programmers in the room
Caption: they'll be very used to the comments
Caption: like talk about side effects as a
Caption: concept
Caption: you want to keep your domain logic like
Caption: the business logic of what you're trying
Caption: to do that should be kept pure if
Caption: there's anything if there's any Bodo
Caption: calls or AWS SDK calls anyway in your
Caption: business logic you've got a problem
Caption: the business logic shouldn't know it's
Caption: going into AWS or gcp or Azure or you
Caption: know a Raspberry Pi you've got sitting
Caption: on the desk it really shouldn't know
Caption: at the point you've made it so it
Caption: doesn't know
Caption: now I can test locally
Caption: because it's it's just logic that's
Caption: working it doesn't understand about any
Caption: external dependencies in any way so from
Caption: my domain logic I can actually iterate
Caption: on that very locally very very quickly
Caption: then I can independently test that the
Caption: drivers I've got that are interacting
Caption: with the cloud vendor
Caption: our work is expected and then some
Caption: end-to-end tests to stitch it together
Caption: this forces you to structure your code
Caption: in a particular way I didn't have enough
Caption: time to kind of go into a lot of depth
Caption: with it today but if you go look at
Caption: clean architecture there's a book
Caption: floating around there if you have a look
Caption: at the way they structure code
Caption: um that's generally how we do it
Caption: nowaday's been doing for a few years
Caption: it's worked very well for this
Caption: um potentially how I go on time and I
Caption: know I'm stopping everyone from lunch I
Caption: might have a chance to show an example
Caption: but we'll see how we go
Caption: um
Caption: one of these things is when you get to
Caption: this point
Caption: um you can this is a make file that I
Caption: use there's a Three Musketeers pattern
Caption: we use at Contino which I'm a big
Caption: proponent of
Caption: um effectively you abstract all your
Caption: repos and make files to make it
Caption: wonderful
Caption: um this is a internal project the make
Caption: file from an internal project and I've
Caption: abstract it a little bit and taken some
Caption: stuff out but when you look at testing
Caption: and kind of setting up local development
Caption: there's no Docker nonsense in here
Caption: there's no setting up databases there's
Caption: no orchestrating a million dependencies
Caption: locally to do things and they have split
Caption: my tests up into integration and not
Caption: integration so I can very easily run my
Caption: local tests that'll run really fast and
Caption: check all my domain logic works and then
Caption: I can run integration tests and
Caption: separation and then for CI I've got to
Caption: test everything on report coverage right
Caption: because when you struck to the test like
Caption: that to get coverage you kind of need
Caption: both running and they've got some
Caption: end-to-end stuff that I did with bdd and
Caption: behave in in this example
Caption: but really I always
Caption: um shudder to think when I see what
Caption: level of complexity people take on to
Caption: try and get their testing apparatus set
Caption: up like okay now I've got to run Docker
Caption: I've got to run local stack oh I have to
Caption: kind of actually get on top of the AWS
Caption: SDK that I'm using to make sure it's
Caption: actually point to local stack apis
Caption: okay that you know all of a sudden it's
Caption: like well it worked on my machine yeah
Caption: who cares like that so not a valuable
Caption: thing
Caption: um you want to be actually I want it to
Caption: work in address I want to be confident
Caption: that it works and really the amount of
Caption: competition get locally is pretty pretty
Caption: low when it comes down to it
Caption: this is a really interesting one I find
Caption: in serverless
Caption: um because I've done it and it's quite
Caption: quite a cool thing to do like the
Caption: testing heuristic like if if you kept
Caption: all your tests but deleted all the code
Caption: how confident are you that if you wrote
Caption: a new code it would work would you feel
Caption: confident running that to production yes
Caption: or no I've gone through the point of
Caption: actually deleting functions because I
Caption: hated the way I read it initially and
Caption: rewrote it and pushed that to production
Caption: with sufficient testing like this is the
Caption: best heuristic I've found in the case of
Caption: like okay well how do I know that my
Caption: tests are sufficient and it this is the
Caption: best thing like if you lose your code
Caption: today but you've got your testing there
Caption: you should be able to get close back to
Caption: production quality very very very
Caption: quickly
Caption: um yeah uh local stack I've already
Caption: mentioned in more times than I plan to
Caption: but now I'm going to mention it a whole
Caption: bunch more either so I can run locally I
Caption: am saved
Caption: um now I've done projects with local
Caption: stack I I've done done a lot with it to
Caption: be honest in the past
Caption: um
Caption: it's just not how to do things in the
Caption: cloud native sense yes you can emulate
Caption: your address locally but why what what
Caption: actually leads us down the path of test
Caption: doubles because generally in the past it
Caption: was yeah at a testable at a mark
Caption: run some kind of slimmed down system
Caption: that kind of responds like the real
Caption: thing
Caption: and they're fundamentally for when
Caption: orchestrating the dependency was too
Caption: expensive now
Caption: what classifies as expensive in here can
Caption: be the amount of time it takes to
Caption: substantiate maybe as a high running
Caption: cost maybe you have to talk with other
Caption: teams to set them up like obviously if
Caption: you've got a sap install or something
Caption: like that you can't just run up a new
Caption: sap install to test against that's not a
Caption: realistic thing to do and I'll talk
Caption: about some strategies you can use for
Caption: that as we go on a little bit but
Caption: generally in serverless like yeah you're
Caption: trying to show that actually managing
Caption: independency is more expensive than the
Caption: test double therefore the test double is
Caption: worth having
Caption: but when you get to serverless
Caption: all those things that kind of drove the
Caption: dependency costs are no longer true
Caption: um hard to configure you've got
Caption: infrastructure as code you know running
Caption: up a Dynamo tables 20 seconds like it's
Caption: not that hard to actually configure
Caption: anymore High running costs most server
Caption: stuff is completely paper use if you're
Caption: using it for testing and just leave it
Caption: alone it will cost
Caption: cents a month right when you contrast to
Caption: compare this about how much a developer
Caption: costs a day and I normally use kind of a
Caption: benchmark of roughly a thousand dollars
Caption: a day
Caption: any time like if my developer has to
Caption: spend two minutes on this every day it's
Caption: more expensive than just running all the
Caption: stuff leaving all the stuff running and
Caption: generally in serverless if you're doing
Caption: it correctly with autonomous teams and
Caption: everything else you don't generally have
Caption: dependencies on other teams you have
Caption: empowered teams you're able to take
Caption: control of this for themselves
Caption: um we all know that handoffs are where
Caption: productivity goes to die
Caption: um so you know
Caption: generally if you find the empowered
Caption: teams thing really hard to do no
Caption: technology is going to save you you need
Caption: to revisit how you've actually
Caption: structured the organization
Caption: um just one of those things
Caption: so one of the common refrains and I even
Caption: get this internally and I've had this
Caption: debate so many times it's one of the
Caption: reasons for writing this talk because I
Caption: got sick of writing the same thing in
Caption: slack every week people always like oh
Caption: but then I want to run a local test and
Caption: oh it takes a while to stand up the
Caption: infrastructure and I don't want to do
Caption: that every time I run my tests I said
Caption: who said that you're standing up the
Caption: infrastructure every single time you run
Caption: your test Suite that's that's insane why
Caption: would you do that
Caption: um this is just some python code that
Caption: I've used and I don't want to think how
Caption: many repos now
Caption: um that effectively just dump jumps in
Caption: and runs terraform in it terraform
Caption: um approve uh terraform apply and
Caption: terraform destroy what you'll notice is
Caption: there is a like environment variable
Caption: escape hatch
Caption: that if I set that environment to local
Caption: I can just stand up the terraform once
Caption: outside of my test suite and it'll be
Caption: long-lived it's not going to get
Caption: automatically torn down so I can lift
Caption: stuff up for the whole day and then pull
Caption: it down at the end of the day
Caption: so then when I'm actually running these
Caption: tests my data layer and all that kind of
Caption: stuff is long-lived so I'm not having to
Caption: wait every time for terraformal car
Caption: information or what have you to do
Caption: things instead for CI it defaults to
Caption: running new stuff up and see how you
Caption: want under 10 minutes like don't overly
Caption: stress about like my CI job took more
Caption: than two minutes now I'm losing
Caption: productivity it's not worth optimization
Caption: kind of Beyond 10 that seems to be the
Caption: general rule of thumb and generally with
Caption: terraform and cloud formation most stuff
Caption: you can rig up in two minutes and then
Caption: have all your tests run on top
Caption: um this was of an example that you know
Caption: something I did for a client back in the
Caption: UK with AWS config because some AWS
Caption: stuff like Dynamo DBW you can build up
Caption: it's yours you can deal with it
Caption: something like AWS config and this is
Caption: again kind of working at the platform
Caption: level I was trying to build the Lambda
Caption: function that aggregated certain config
Caption: rules across the entire organization
Caption: reported kind of a classification of
Caption: resources
Caption: now AWS config will give me different
Caption: responses every single day because
Caption: people change things and I can't control
Caption: that I can't tell everyone no stop you
Caption: can't deploy resources because I need to
Caption: test my thing
Caption: so this kind of comes from the react
Caption: testing House of snapshot testing so
Caption: people have done um unfortunately had to
Caption: do front end work which I honestly hate
Caption: um then you will come across snapshot
Caption: testing in here within python there's a
Caption: library called Placebo that allows you
Caption: to effectively you call AWS once and it
Caption: stores the response so next time you're
Caption: on your test it replays that response
Caption: back to you
Caption: this is higher Fidelity than local stack
Caption: because it's actually coming from AWS
Caption: and it allows you to actually test
Caption: things properly so I can you know verify
Caption: that my function running actually does
Caption: um
Caption: it does give me the right responses and
Caption: like has anyone ever configured local
Caption: stack with the python helper because
Caption: it's about five times more code than
Caption: that just to make it work this is really
Caption: really simple they get get committed to
Caption: get everyone's working from the same
Caption: thing really really simple to do if you
Caption: can't um control if you can't
Caption: orchestrate the dependency properly then
Caption: you can just capture the responses you
Caption: can refresh it occasionally but don't
Caption: change your code and try and do the
Caption: refresh at the same time it's one or the
Caption: other
Caption: um
Caption: there are better things there are more
Caption: Cloud native things there are things far
Caption: more in line with what we want to do AWS
Caption: themselves have released some accelerate
Caption: serverless framework has a similar thing
Caption: where instead as you make code changes
Caption: they are live streamed in data s you get
Caption: full Fidelity testing at speed and you
Caption: get true Cloud native testing when you
Caption: kind of get down to it and as you
Caption: actually properly secure your Cloud
Caption: environments and you actually have
Caption: production like infrastructure running
Caption: as you in the account will not allow you
Caption: to test anymore
Caption: because data should be locked away KMS
Caption: Keys you should not have access I'll
Caption: I'll make the point that generally most
Caption: environments are not set up to this
Caption: level but they should be
Caption: but fundamentally you want to be
Caption: actually assuming the principle of the
Caption: Lambda function or equivalent when
Caption: you're actually doing this testing
Caption: because it actually tells you what's
Caption: actually going to happen
Caption: um you know you'd actually if you try
Caption: and do all this local SEC testing or
Caption: even just testing locally against AWS
Caption: apis or GPS apis or what have you
Caption: if your security matures to a certain
Caption: point it's all going to break
Caption: um and it should break because the
Caption: reality is you should be testing against
Caption: production like infrastructure
Caption: production like infrastructure shouldn't
Caption: be allowing you to get into all the
Caption: databases and pull stuff out as
Caption: willy-nilly to check things have gone
Caption: where they should go right
Caption: um
Caption: so coming back to this refinement piece
Caption: I talked about before when you're
Caption: testing this local stack you are testing
Caption: how your system works in local stack and
Caption: you're bringing your mental model closer
Caption: and closer in tune with that not
Caption: actually with where it's actually
Caption: running in production
Caption: um for example on local stack face fixed
Caption: this ages ago but when I was using it I
Caption: found that the donor DB types were a lot
Caption: looser so what was working in local
Caption: stack when I went to AWS was being
Caption: rejected by the API now you know
Caption: that in and of itself maybe lost me 10
Caption: minutes of time but 10 minutes of time
Caption: multiplied by the amount of devs hitting
Caption: all these random little edge cases and
Caption: all those kind of things
Caption: doesn't really work and also when you
Caption: start to look at local stack yeah kind
Caption: of the basics of that and
Caption: um you've got like the services enough
Caption: to wet like wet your whistle you can get
Caption: in like okay lambda's there Dino's there
Caption: cool I can start working now I want to
Caption: kind of I have x-ray in there and I have
Caption: a whole bunch of other things in here
Caption: looks like cool payers no what this was
Caption: all about saving costs against AWS what
Caption: you tell me I now have to pay a license
Caption: for every single developer are you
Caption: insane and fundamentally these address
Caption: costs are so minuscule like your local
Caption: set cost is going to massively outweigh
Caption: your Cloud Bill and this is insane
Caption: um
Caption: it's kind of on the last
Caption: the last kind of rant I'm going to go on
Caption: um again this is comes from people and
Caption: it's not that these approaches were were
Caption: wrong at the time they were came from a
Caption: certain time certain place certain
Caption: Paradigm and certain ways of working and
Caption: they made a lot of sense
Caption: um the point is that when you go to
Caption: serverless that a lot of you need to
Caption: reevaluate how you do things one of
Caption: these things is I mean I've
Caption: hardly ever used a debugger I'm really
Caption: bad with them but you know a lot of the
Caption: time people get used to being able to
Caption: attach a debugger to their running code
Caption: so they've got the variables as they're
Caption: going and all that kind of stuff
Caption: and then they get to this point like how
Caption: do I attach my debugger to the Lambda
Caption: functions you can't you know people used
Caption: to do what seems in retrospect insane
Caption: where they'd like go onto a production
Caption: system attach a debugger to a running
Caption: Java process to have a look at what's
Caption: going on
Caption: um you know in my mind that's insane but
Caption: I can also understand why they did it at
Caption: the time but nowadays you know that's
Caption: not an option and you shouldn't be
Caption: annoyed that's not an option but some
Caption: people do get annoyed
Caption: um you know this this is just apps a
Caption: classic meme within the space right
Caption: um the thing is it used to be loaded at
Caption: as being ridiculous when in reality it's
Caption: actually the case of how you should be
Caption: doing things for a large part you know
Caption: we always come out with the adage that
Caption: you know code is read 10 more times than
Caption: it's written the reality is it's run in
Caption: production thousands and millions of
Caption: times for every time it's written for
Caption: any code that's doing a lot of stuff
Caption: so really where you need to focus your
Caption: efforts is in how do I understand when
Caption: stuff breaks in production more so than
Caption: how do I fix stuff locally
Caption: one of the things that I do a lot with
Caption: teams
Caption: um is beginning with the end in mind and
Caption: this is trying to bring SRE principles
Caption: in just just kind of service all
Caption: objectives not the other six
Caption: um but just looking at how can I use
Caption: Services objectives to Define what I'm
Caption: doing
Caption: um you kind of got whenever you're kind
Caption: of developing anything really and these
Caption: are two questions that every single
Caption: feature should be asked is how will I
Caption: know my feature is broken and that gives
Caption: you your like mean time to
Caption: identification and how will I determine
Caption: why it's broken which is my your mean
Caption: time to recovery if
Caption: on every like pull request review if
Caption: you're not asking these questions you're
Caption: going to end up pushing code which isn't
Caption: operationally sound maybe functionally
Caption: correct but when it blows up you're
Caption: going to be really sorry at the end
Caption: right
Caption: um
Caption: for me you should be looking at this one
Caption: first
Caption: before you actually develop the feature
Caption: you should be building the apparatus
Caption: that allows you to understand your
Caption: feature is broken
Caption: and then second you can just type in why
Caption: it's broken
Caption: so SLI is slos slas I talk about these
Caption: way too much but for anyone that's not
Caption: not familiar
Caption: service level SLI service indicators
Caption: defines your success and failure so for
Caption: the feature how can I measure that it
Caption: was successful or failed in production
Caption: what's actually look like
Caption: service level objective then defines
Caption: what an acceptable failure frequency is
Caption: so you know for every thousand requests
Caption: one's allowed to fail something like
Caption: that expressed as percentages I'm sure
Caption: you've kind of all seen slas floating
Caption: around and then an SLA is a like
Caption: contractual obligation defines a penalty
Caption: for every time you actually fall
Caption: underneath that failure goal
Caption: um reality most systems you can just
Caption: stop at slos especially for internal
Caption: systems
Caption: um one one thing I'm going to get into
Caption: here which is just something that always
Caption: shits me is an SLO written in Confluence
Caption: doesn't mean anything at all
Caption: um I call them schroding as slos because
Caption: no one knows whether it's alive or dead
Caption: um I hate the I hate how often I see
Caption: systems where people don't know where
Caption: their system's alive or dead they're
Caption: just kind of hoping it is
Caption: um you know
Caption: not going to say anything about putting
Caption: them in a box with poison and waiting
Caption: for a timer
Caption: um one thing that we've done and this is
Caption: going open source this is not a sales
Caption: pitch please don't take it as one
Caption: whereas we built at container I built
Caption: this for a client in the UK a um a way
Caption: of dashboarding things in AWS that was
Caption: SLO focused that we kept kind of it's
Caption: all serverless all very extensible
Caption: um but this you know when we on the team
Caption: I built this with
Caption: the first thing we did for every new
Caption: feature was added to the SLO dashboard
Caption: before we started working on the feature
Caption: you can see some at the bottom around
Caption: patching compliance testing and backups
Caption: and stuff like that I built the backups
Caption: was one I did just before I left where
Caption: we were running out a new backup
Caption: solution so the first thing I did was
Caption: roll out and this was where the config
Caption: bit came in as well the ability to
Caption: understand how many instances are
Caption: currently outside of backup plans how
Caption: many don't have active backups with the
Caption: idea that as I build the backup solution
Caption: and roll it out and this is on a this is
Caption: across 500 AWS accounts you can
Caption: understand why I'm trying to track these
Caption: numbers because you can't possibly hold
Caption: that in your head but I wanted to be
Caption: able to show as we roll it out that
Caption: these numbers going down
Caption: because otherwise you're a backup
Caption: solution and this is a classic thing we
Caption: built the tool is anyone using the tool
Caption: I don't know
Caption: okay why do you build it
Caption: and really fundamentally when you're
Caption: doing this Cloud native development and
Caption: talking about testing and getting into
Caption: debugging you should be trying to debug
Caption: your development with the same tools
Caption: you're going to use to debug in
Caption: production
Caption: because otherwise and this is another
Caption: rant of mine debug logs why do they
Caption: exist why do they ever get committed to
Caption: Mainline because you get them in
Caption: production I'll be able to figure this
Caption: out I've had the debug logs
Caption: great what are you going to do about it
Caption: now if you if you wrote These logs to
Caption: understand things in development you
Caption: should be turning them on in production
Caption: as well I I yeah it's just a rant of
Caption: behind because again going back in time
Caption: you used to be able to switch on debug
Caption: logs by changing the environment
Caption: variable or something like that you
Caption: can't really do that anymore and even if
Caption: you can like
Caption: transient issues that you see that have
Caption: disappeared and you really wish I had
Caption: that log data oh it's gone oh well too
Caption: bad right
Caption: um really you get down to what you end
Caption: up with you know be able to use X-ray
Caption: and cloudwatch
Caption: um you know grafana Prometheus all these
Caption: kind of tools in production and you know
Caption: Cloud operations suite and Azure logic
Caption: monitor you know yeah you apply the
Caption: tools synonyms for whatever Cloud you
Caption: use
Caption: um but really if you can't use these to
Caption: figure out why your development's not
Caption: working how are you going to use them to
Caption: figure out a production is not working
Caption: um you know debugger and local tools and
Caption: that kind of stuff you're not going to
Caption: have them when you really need them
Caption: so why are you focused on becoming
Caption: really strong with them
Caption: like when you look at honeycomb and
Caption: observability which I suggest everyone
Caption: do you know they instrument everything
Caption: and they use honeycomb for all their all
Caption: their kind of needs it allows you to
Caption: actually just yeah
Caption: your code's going to be running in
Caption: production for much longer than it takes
Caption: you to write it you should be focusing
Caption: on that
Caption: um and when you get good with the
Caption: production tools they're not going to
Caption: slow down your development Cycles by
Caption: using these things but it makes a lot
Caption: more sense than trying to use a debugger
Caption: locally and then getting stuck in
Caption: production
Caption: so I'm actually running ahead of time
Caption: which is nice unusual for me and I know
Caption: I'm keeping everyone from lunch so you
Caption: know go figure I just wanted to kind of
Caption: revisit back revisit back on the three
Caption: key lessons the one testing query is
Caption: anti-pattern there's the testing
Caption: honeycomb that
Caption: um Spotify have
Caption: it's better I still think as an industry
Caption: we can do better than that
Caption: um emulating College the rest of your
Caption: disappointment I hope any of you that
Caption: are using local stack or equivalents
Caption: today
Caption: um maybe maybe I might get lucky and
Caption: some of you might revisit that decision
Caption: next week I understand that it's
Caption: investment and everything else and oh
Caption: we're going to change the way we test
Caption: makes our product owner cry
Caption: um because they're not getting any
Caption: features but you know you need that time
Caption: to actually invest in you know paying
Caption: down Tech debt and to be honest if
Caption: you're using local stack I would
Caption: classify that as technical debt nowadays
Caption: um unless it's testing is a shopping
Caption: code hits production you really like
Caption: that's what you should be focusing for
Caption: because that's where your code delivers
Caption: value and where braking actually becomes
Caption: a problem so yeah fundamentally look at
Caption: what tools are in the cloud that you can
Caption: use to understand your production code
Caption: use those for your development code at
Caption: the same time
Caption: that that was all I had so hopefully
Caption: there's some questions
Caption: first of all Josh I love your brutally
Caption: honest approach
Caption: um it is fantastic it's very real I just
Caption: wanted to throw that out there question
Caption: oh sorry
Caption: sorry yeah so um I guess if you need to
Caption: keep CI tests fast
Caption: um that requires that you're able to
Caption: kind of spin up an ephemeral stack and
Caption: then tear it down in a matter of minutes
Caption: like what patterns
Caption: um would you use when you have like a
Caption: hybrid architecture where you kind of
Caption: necessarily have one or two server full
Caption: resources say AWS elasticsearch for
Caption: example
Caption: yeah at that point you've got to make
Caption: like a trade-off at some point for going
Caption: well the cost of keeping it running
Caption: versus the time saving you should be
Caption: able to kind of when I come back to that
Caption: kind of thousand dollars a day you can
Caption: run the data and go it's going to be
Caption: more effective to do it one way or the
Caption: other but I think it would be try and
Caption: get the data together to go running
Caption: elasticsearch is going to cost us this
Caption: much if we just leave it on
Caption: okay well is that worth the speed up and
Caption: development time for that like it comes
Caption: down to you've got you've got to make
Caption: trade-offs you just want to make the
Caption: cheapest trade-off whatever that is
Caption: um but yeah elasticsearch is a pain and
Caption: it's expensive as well so it's a hard
Caption: one and in that case you might want to
Caption: actually eat the CI rung or yeah
Caption: generally have some kind of mocked
Caption: version of elasticsearch I'm not saying
Caption: you can't Mock I'm just saying don't
Caption: default to it if it's going to be
Caption: cheaper and you're going to get the
Caption: Fidelity you want then Mark away but
Caption: just it should be not the default
Caption: position it should be yeah the other
Caption: ones are too expensive we need to go
Caption: down this path
Caption: fantastic next one
Caption: alrighty heckler's in the front audience
Caption: now I am told you are here to Hackle so
Caption: have we got any heckling
Caption: no right all right so disappointing
Caption: looks like uh I'm gonna get all the
Caption: books so uh joking seriously if we've
Caption: got any questions guys please put your
Caption: hand up
Caption: fantastic thank you
Caption: what's your opinion on uh so Docker
Caption: versus Lambda so you know running native
Caption: Native lambdas versus running
Caption: Docker containers or Docker serverless
Caption: or
Caption: um I mean with container
Caption: yeah I like I like Dockers for I like
Caption: Docker using Docker images Docker
Caption: containers for local development to try
Caption: and get some standardization on
Caption: environments but if you're throwing them
Caption: into production
Caption: be aware that you're accepting a high
Caption: level of accountability when it comes to
Caption: your security posture in terms of
Caption: managing the containers fixing
Caption: vulnerabilities all that kind of stuff
Caption: like you know when you're in a lamp when
Caption: you're running Lambda without containers
Caption: you know AWS fixed stuff for you
Caption: underneath if you've got a container
Caption: strategy and everything else and you've
Caption: got all that kind of stuff in-house
Caption: because maybe you've got some kubernetes
Caption: somewhere else and whatever and you can
Caption: kind of piggyback on that but I still
Caption: generally try and go with Native Lambda
Caption: where possible because it's less work
Caption: for me to do from a security perspective
Caption: operationally it's not fantastically
Caption: different but still dockier pulling
Caption: extra packages that you have to rotate
Caption: and fix the CVS for
Caption: um I think Sheldon had one
Caption: awesome
Caption: one repo one function Primal and a mono
Caption: repo mono repo
Caption: what one
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: one one Function One repo which my God
Caption: you'd hit you GitHub limits in about a
Caption: week um but uh
Caption: like
Caption: I always think start with monorepo
Caption: because it's easier and you can wait
Caption: till you hit a scaling Point you're like
Caption: actually multiple work for us like
Caption: normally when I've started a multi repo
Caption: before and it's like okay well now we
Caption: need to share this kind of package of
Caption: types around between the repos now I've
Caption: got to figure all that out and it's like
Caption: um now we've got to push dependency yeah
Caption: we've got pull dependency version
Caption: Independence he's like oh what's the
Caption: value in doing this oh we have multiple
Caption: repos yeah but what's the value multiple
Caption: repos like if you're working in vertical
Caption: slice and you have your code set up
Caption: properly that you shouldn't be hitting
Caption: like merge conflicts all the time or
Caption: anything like that and at least it keeps
Caption: your code more consistent more easily
Caption: um I've kind of gone back and forth on
Caption: this over the years but at the moment I
Caption: just go monore until I feel the pain
Caption: especially if you do clean architecture
Caption: like you end up with one code base that
Caption: you kind of change the entry points for
Caption: to do different Lambda functions so you
Caption: end up with just kind of one blob of
Caption: code that you deploy in different kind
Caption: of configurations to do things
Caption: um which is generally a lot easier from
Caption: a packaging point of view it makes stuff
Caption: a lot simpler
Caption: well done because I didn't know what you
Caption: were going to answer to my why because I
Caption: am not sure what I'm on Reaper is if I'm
Caption: honest guys so sorry for throwing you a
Caption: little bit for success
Caption: have you applied these techniques in a
Caption: kubernetes environment
Caption: yeah I mean it's
Caption: not fundamentally all that different it
Caption: depends on how much managed Services
Caption: you're running and all that kind of
Caption: stuff but effectively I think the
Caption: patterns still apply like when I um did
Caption: some work for one of the mining
Caption: companies in town a few years ago and we
Caption: built it and we deployed it into Lambda
Caption: and ECS from the same code base we just
Caption: had to change stuff on the edge and it
Caption: was the same approach for both
Caption: um there's nothing like effectively your
Caption: code to a larger we really shouldn't
Caption: understand where the hell it's being
Caption: deployed
Caption: um and you should be trying to take
Caption: those changes and push them right out to
Caption: the far edge of your code again clean
Caption: architecture helps a lot with this but
Caption: yeah running in kubernetes or not the
Caption: same principles I think still apply of
Caption: just try and use the cloud as much as
Caption: possible and stop trying to run like a
Caption: postgres database locally or whatever
Caption: um like you shouldn't need to I mean
Caption: postgres is a little bit different
Caption: because it's such a standard like stable
Caption: platform that the emulation is generally
Caption: very very high fidelity but still like
Caption: you know try and figure out what you can
Caption: do cheapest
Caption: and generally developer time is the is
Caption: the big one for cheap families don't I
Caption: know sometimes you guys have different
Caption: ideas on that but for most of us it's
Caption: developer time you guys have scaled
Caption: problems that all of us wish we had so
Caption: it changes the needle sometimes
Caption: alrighty we can probably fit one more
Caption: question and if we have it
Caption: thanks guys
Caption: um do you kind of have any thoughts on
Caption: what might be good kinds of production
Caption: tests to do and maybe sort of
Caption: organizational pushback on doing that
Caption: kind of thing
Caption: I mean yeah organizations really always
Caption: push back on testing I think is that um
Caption: I really like the service lab objective
Caption: stuff I really like being able to
Caption: understand
Caption: Um how my feature is supposed to be
Caption: working I'm going to track how that
Caption: feature is working and having just that
Caption: really quick feedback I can see I'm
Caption: burning our budget so something's gone
Caption: wrong I do think the SRE looking at SRE
Caption: for how to run stuff in production is
Caption: probably the way to go but I would say
Caption: that's SRE as in like the Google Books
Caption: not what a lot of vendors sell
Caption: um today because I've had so many
Caption: arguments on redefining it at
Caption: Enterprises where gsi's got him first
Caption: and they're like oh and then there's a
Caption: rebadged ITIL build and run that's not
Caption: what SRE is
Caption: um I think in production is pretty much
Caption: like how do I know something's broken is
Caption: is the big thing and service level
Caption: objectives are probably the the kind of
Caption: the becoming dominant way of doing that
Caption: like there is the classic monitoring of
Caption: my CPU is spiking send an alert and it's
Caption: like no that's you need the kind of
Caption: business impact level metrics to
Caption: understand that customers are being
Caption: impacted because you measure from the
Caption: customer then CPU spiking useful
Caption: diagnostic metric when you're in kind of
Caption: debug mode but you shouldn't be alerting
Caption: and actually be alerting on you know
Caption: weighing so many 500 like 500 responses
Caption: of spiking something's gone wrong on our
Caption: API cool let's go and fix that
Caption: um again observability in honeycomb is
Caption: the big kind of I think it's the big
Caption: paradigm shift that's coming
Caption: um where you've got like high
Caption: cardinality events okay I definitely do
Caption: not have time to get into that in any
Caption: great detail but I can afterwards if
Caption: you'd like more than happy to
Caption: 100 look guys that's probably time Josh
Caption: but a big round of applause
Caption: um that was Unreal
Caption: now just a few friendly reminders lunch
Caption: will be immediately served once you
Caption: leave this store now you can go to the
Caption: North or the South we
Caption: we've stuck over in front of the theater
Caption: room there's going to be food sort of
Caption: everywhere basically from what I'm
Caption: reading here uh lunchtime sessions will
Caption: commence at 2 30
Caption: 5 in the theater that's definitely a
Caption: typo at 1 35 in the theater and both the
Caption: river rooms notes do not do what I did
Caption: before and eat your Apple because you
Caption: will get in trouble in there
Caption: um attendees there will also be breakout
Caption: sessions that will commence again
Caption: at
Caption: 2 15.
Caption: definitely 2 15 and I've got one in here
Caption: with a wonderful wonderful lady and she
Caption: will be talking about standing on this
Caption: standing on the shoulder of giants the
Caption: next great generation in Tech nichu so
Caption: on that note thank you again Josh thank
Caption: you Hercules and everybody have a great
Caption: lunch
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: uh okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends I'm Scott Hanselman and I
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our movies
Caption: always want joy and Scott
Caption: what do you want
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: congratulations
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three more days we need it ASAP okay
Caption: team what's the status on the app we're
Caption: good to go accept our login experience
Caption: is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: flawlessly because because I don't want
Caption: to lose one single customer I hear you
Caption: so let's use off zero off what now off
Caption: zero it's an identity platform fast easy
Caption: logins just what the boss wants can we
Caption: make our own authentication Service come
Caption: on the Ultimate key master you know we
Caption: don't have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use Siri can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up I will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep I think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it I got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what I want a bodyguard hey we
Caption: got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's Stephen
Caption: what's up Stephen
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: thank you
Caption: all right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh okay you can you can
Caption: see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends I'm Scott hansman and I was
Caption: told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our movies
Caption: foreign
Caption: what do you want
Caption: oh my chocolate
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a Fearless hunger for
Caption: Success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using AI to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100
Caption: 000 teammates ambition is how a
Caption: Children's Hospital built an app to
Caption: reduce stress for families ambition is
Caption: how a law firm rallied against a malware
Caption: attack to reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at Insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young Brothers
Caption: to a Fortune 500 company offering I.T
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be now is
Caption: the time to do big things together now
Caption: is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is Carol I'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case it might be
Caption: familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because I like
Caption: eating I eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me Carol why are you eating
Caption: and I think that's just when they see
Caption: when they see the cereal box they say
Caption: okay that's Carol
Caption: hi I'm joshni I'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because I always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation I'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is Jayden I'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at Planet my core sign is
Caption: digit because I'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major
Caption: um but I often get called out
Caption: on how I never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths I just love maths
Caption: I am Cassandra I am a test at the
Caption: mission especially being a beret as you
Caption: can tell by Jackson I am French very
Caption: very prominent accent so it's a very
Caption: completely makes sense as for the thing
Caption: no matter as a client no matter where I
Caption: was working it always was a big
Caption: background with Hello Kitty riding a
Caption: unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who I am outside
Caption: clearly but I think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: um Sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: buried it is
Caption: my name is Kong I'm a consultant here at
Caption: Planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name I always say I'm
Caption: not the king but the Kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: I am the king and I'm the Kong
Caption: work to inspire it's very something that
Caption: we live by I believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we have for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for Target we
Caption: always try to go a little bit further
Caption: and we try to inspire each other by
Caption: learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and I think
Caption: it's very inspiring be better build
Caption: better personally I always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so I'm better than
Caption: yesterday and I'll be better tomorrow
Caption: but I also got a lot of training
Caption: opportunities and planning because
Caption: there's a
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that I can just access anytime before I
Caption: join Planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something go first right and then when
Caption: you Google something you always have to
Caption: pay for something and that's not that's
Caption: not what I want to do so it's really
Caption: it's really good that planet offers
Caption: these free courses for me and I don't
Caption: have to feel pressured about buying
Caption: something just so I can improve my
Caption: skills and use them for work Planet
Caption: always encourages learning and learning
Caption: is a good way to just accelerate your
Caption: career growth Top Line of testing is um
Caption: it's awesome it's it's really cool to be
Caption: around people who are so passionate so
Caption: driven to do what they do and who always
Caption: want to want to learn and get better I
Caption: think that's really important I think
Caption: it's going to be a driving Factor going
Caption: forward in in the IT industry in general
Caption: top world is the best of the best and
Caption: for me it's uh if you want to grow up in
Caption: your career you are at the right place
Caption: because we have got all the training
Caption: materials right people and right
Caption: opportunities yeah what do you need to
Caption: progress in your career you have got
Caption: everything in here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: um okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: Scott Hanselman and I was told to give
Caption: you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: nerds nerding what we're doing is we're
Caption: talking to people all over the world
Caption: because we're stuck in our places
Caption: wanted to join Scott henselon true
Caption: what do you want
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while I was gone I made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then I helped him make his work much
Caption: better and we found the perfect outfit
Caption: to wear to my party
Caption: but I really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so I turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best for me you being back
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: Market leading Technology Solutions
Caption: through our life cycle Services we help
Caption: clients realize business outcomes
Caption: through our advice integration and
Caption: operational services
Caption: mlq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their I.T needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh okay you can you can
Caption: see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends I'm Scott hansman and I was
Caption: told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our movies
Caption: foreign
Caption: what do you want
Caption: oh my God
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three more days we need it ASAP okay
Caption: team what's the status on the app we're
Caption: good to go accept our login experience
Caption: is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: flawlessly because because I don't want
Caption: to lose one single customer I hear you
Caption: so let's use off zero off what now off
Caption: zero it's an identity platform fast easy
Caption: logins just what the boss wants can we
Caption: make our own authentication Service come
Caption: on the ultimate keymaster you know we
Caption: don't have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use Siri can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up I will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep I think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it I cut a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what I want a bodyguard hey we
Caption: got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's Stephen
Caption: what's up Stephen
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: all right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: uh okay you can't you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends I'm Scott Hanselman and I
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: nerds nerding what we're doing is we're
Caption: talking to people all over the world
Caption: because we're stuck in our focuses
Caption: what joy and Scott have someone who
Caption: what do you want
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: relations
Caption: ambition is a Fearless hunger for
Caption: Success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using AI to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100
Caption: 000 teammates ambition is how a
Caption: Children's Hospital built an app to
Caption: reduce stress for families ambition is
Caption: how a law firm rallied against a malware
Caption: attack to reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at Insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young Brothers
Caption: to a Fortune 500 company offering I.T
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be now is
Caption: the time to do big things together now
Caption: is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: my name is Carol I'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because I like
Caption: eating I eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me Carol why are you eating
Caption: and I think that's just when they see
Caption: when they see the cereal box they say
Caption: okay that's Carol
Caption: hi I'm joshni I'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because I always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation I'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is Jayden I'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at Planet my core sign is
Caption: digit because I'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: uh it is it is it is my primary major
Caption: um but I often get called out
Caption: on how I never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths I just love maths
Caption: I am Cassandra I am a desk at the
Caption: mission specialist being a beret as you
Caption: can tell by Jackson I am French very
Caption: very prominent accent so it's a very
Caption: completely makes sense as for the thing
Caption: no matter as a client no matter where I
Caption: was working it always was a big
Caption: background with Hello Kitty riding a
Caption: unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who I am outside
Caption: clearly but I think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: um Sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: buried it is
Caption: my name is Kong I'm a consultant here at
Caption: Planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name I always say I'm
Caption: not the king but the Kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: I am the king and I'm the Kong
Caption: work to inspire it's very something that
Caption: we live by I believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we have for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for Target we
Caption: always try to go a little bit further
Caption: and we try to inspire each other by
Caption: learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and I think
Caption: it's very inspiring be better build
Caption: better personally I always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so I'm better than
Caption: yesterday and I'll be better tomorrow
Caption: but I also got a lot of training
Caption: opportunities and planning because
Caption: there's a
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that I can just access anytime before I
Caption: join Planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something go first right and then when
Caption: you Google something you always have to
Caption: pay for something and that's not that's
Caption: not what I want to do so it's really
Caption: it's really good that planet offers
Caption: these free courses for me and I don't
Caption: have to feel pressured about buying
Caption: something just so I can improve my
Caption: skills and use them for work Planet
Caption: always encourages learning and learning
Caption: is a good way to just accelerate your
Caption: career growth Top Line of testing is um
Caption: it's awesome it's it's really cool to be
Caption: around people who are so passionate so
Caption: driven to do what they do and who always
Caption: want to want to learn and get better I
Caption: think that's really important I think
Caption: it's going to be a driving Factor going
Caption: forward in in the IT industry in general
Caption: top world is the best of the best and
Caption: for me it's if you want to grow up in
Caption: your career you are at the right place
Caption: because we have got all the training
Caption: materials right people and right
Caption: opportunities yeah what do you need to
Caption: progress in your career you have got
Caption: everything in here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: thank you foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: all right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh okay you can you can
Caption: see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends I'm Scott hansman and I was
Caption: told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck
Caption: my dream come true I've always wanted to
Caption: join Scott henselman too
Caption: foreign
Caption: what do you want
Caption: oh my chocolate
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while I was gone I made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then I helped him make his work much
Caption: better and we found the perfect outfit
Caption: to wear to my party
Caption: but I really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so I turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying Market leading Technology
Caption: Solutions through our life cycle
Caption: Services we help clients realize
Caption: business outcomes through our advice
Caption: integration and operational services
Caption: mlq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their I.T needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: all right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh okay you can you can
Caption: see me yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends I'm Scott hansman and I was
Caption: told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh cap is almost
Caption: ready uh we just need
Caption: three more days we need it ASAP okay
Caption: team what's the status on the app we're
Caption: good to go accept our login experience
Caption: is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: flawlessly because because I don't want
Caption: to lose one single customer I hear you
Caption: so let's use off zero off what now off
Caption: zero it's an identity platform fast easy
Caption: logins just what the boss wants can we
Caption: make our own authentication Service come
Caption: on the Ultimate key master you know we
Caption: don't have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use Siri can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up I will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep I think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it I cut a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what I want a bodyguard hey we
Caption: got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's Stephen
Caption: what's up Steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: all right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh okay you can you can
Caption: see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends I'm Scott Hanselman and I
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck
Caption: my dream come true I've always wanted a
Caption: joy and Scott have someone true
Caption: foreign
Caption: what do you want
Caption: oh my chocolate
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a Fearless hunger for
Caption: Success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using AI to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100
Caption: 000 teammates ambition is how a
Caption: Children's Hospital built an app to
Caption: reduce stress for families ambition is
Caption: how a law firm rallied against a malware
Caption: attack to reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at Insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young Brothers
Caption: to a Fortune 500 company offering I.T
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be now is
Caption: the time to do big things together now
Caption: is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is Carol I'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case it might be
Caption: familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because I like
Caption: eating I eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating they always
Caption: ask me Carol why are you eating and I
Caption: think that just when they see when they
Caption: see the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: Carol
Caption: hi I'm joshni I'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me Jester because I always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation I'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is Jayden I'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at Planet my core sign is
Caption: digit because I'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major
Caption: um but I often get called out
Caption: on how I never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths I just love maths
Caption: I am Cassandra I am a desk at the
Caption: mission specialist being a beret as you
Caption: can tell by Jackson I am French very
Caption: very premium accent so it's a very
Caption: completely makes sense as for the thing
Caption: no matter as a client no matter where I
Caption: was working it always was a big
Caption: background with Hello Kitty riding a
Caption: unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who I am outside
Caption: clearly but I think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: um Sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: buried it is
Caption: my name is Kong I'm a consultant here at
Caption: Planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name I always say I'm
Caption: not the king but the Kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: I am the king and I'm the Kong
Caption: work to inspire it's very something that
Caption: we live by I believe we definitely see
Caption: how much fashion we have for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for Target we
Caption: always try to go a little bit further
Caption: and we try to inspire each other by
Caption: learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and I think
Caption: it's very inspiring be better build
Caption: better personally I always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so I'm better than
Caption: yesterday and I'll be better tomorrow
Caption: but I also got a lot of training
Caption: opportunities and planning because
Caption: there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that I can just access anytime before I
Caption: join Planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something go first right and then when
Caption: you Google something you always have to
Caption: pay for something and that's not that's
Caption: not what I want to do so it's really
Caption: it's really good that planet offers
Caption: these free courses for me and I don't
Caption: have to feel pressured about buying
Caption: something just so I can improve my
Caption: skills and use them for work Planet
Caption: always encourages learning and learning
Caption: is a good way to just accelerate your
Caption: career growth Top Line of testing is um
Caption: it's awesome it's it's really cool to be
Caption: around people who are so passionate so
Caption: driven to do what they do and who always
Caption: want to want to learn and get better I
Caption: think that's really important I think
Caption: it's going to be a driving Factor going
Caption: forward in in the IT industry in general
Caption: top world is the best of the best and
Caption: for me it's uh if you want to grow up in
Caption: your career you are at the right place
Caption: because we have got all the training
Caption: materials right people and right
Caption: opportunities yeah what do you need to
Caption: progress in your career you have got
Caption: everything in here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: uh okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends I'm Scott Hanselman and I
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: nerds nerding what we're doing is we're
Caption: talking to people all over the world
Caption: because we're stuck in our places
Caption: what do you want
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: relations
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while I was gone I made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then I helped him make his work much
Caption: better and we found the perfect outfit
Caption: to wear to my party
Caption: but I really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so I turned my hands into a starfish
Caption: my best friend is you being back
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: Market leading Technology Solutions
Caption: through our life cycle Services we help
Caption: clients realize business outcomes
Caption: through our advice integration and
Caption: operational services
Caption: mlq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their I.T needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh okay you can you can
Caption: see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends I'm Scott hansman and I was
Caption: told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck
Caption: my team come true I've always wanted to
Caption: join Scott have someone true
Caption: foreign
Caption: what do you want
Caption: oh my chocolate
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh he was almost
Caption: ready uh we just need
Caption: three more days we need it ASAP okay
Caption: team what's the status on the app we're
Caption: good to go accept our login experience
Caption: is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: flawlessly because because I don't want
Caption: to lose one single customer I hear you
Caption: so let's use off zero off what now off
Caption: zero it's an identity platform fast easy
Caption: logins just what the boss wants can we
Caption: make our own authentication Service come
Caption: on the ultimate keymaster you know we
Caption: don't have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use upstairs can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up I will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep hey
Caption: bigger customers are gonna love it I cut
Caption: a real app now folks
Caption: you know what I want a bodyguard hey we
Caption: got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's Stephen
Caption: what's up Steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: all right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh okay you can you can
Caption: see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends I'm Scott hansman and I was
Caption: told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our cookies
Caption: foreign
Caption: what do you want
Caption: oh my chocolate
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a Fearless hunger for
Caption: Success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using AI to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for one
Caption: hundred thousand teammates ambition is
Caption: how a Children's Hospital built an app
Caption: to reduce stress for families ambition
Caption: is how a law firm rallied against a
Caption: malware attack to reclaim control and
Caption: prevent a devastating breach of client
Caption: confidence at Insight we know the power
Caption: of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young Brothers
Caption: to a Fortune 500 company offering I.T
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be now is
Caption: the time to do big things together now
Caption: is the time to be ambitious
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: I'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case it might be
Caption: familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because I like
Caption: eating I eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating they always
Caption: ask me Carol why are you eating and I
Caption: think that just when they see when they
Caption: see the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: Carol
Caption: hi I'm Josh need I'm a test engineer
Caption: they call me gesture because I always
Caption: have a smile on my face whatever
Caption: situation I'm in
Caption: my name is Jayden I'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at Planet my cool sign is
Caption: digit because I'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major
Caption: um but I often get called out
Caption: on how I never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths I just love maths
Caption: I am Cassandra I am a guest automation
Caption: specialist being Bureau as you can tell
Caption: by Jackson I am French very very
Caption: prominent accent so it's very completely
Caption: makes sense as for the pink no matter
Caption: the client no matter where I was working
Caption: it always was a pink background with
Caption: Hello Kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who I am outside
Caption: clearly but I think it brings a little
Caption: bit of Sparks and enjoy and so yeah so
Caption: being better it is my name is Kong I'm
Caption: consultant here at Planet and it's when
Caption: people ask me how to pronounce my name I
Caption: always say I'm not the king but the Kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: I am the king and I'm the Kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by I believe we definitely see
Caption: quality and and how much we want to
Caption: convey this as a client we don't just go
Caption: for Target we always try to go a little
Caption: bit further and we try to inspire each
Caption: other by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and I think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally I always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so I'm better than
Caption: yesterday and I'll be better tomorrow
Caption: but I also got a lot of training
Caption: opportunities and planning because
Caption: there's a vast library of training
Caption: courses available that I can just access
Caption: anytime before I join Planet like when
Caption: you want to learn something go first
Caption: right and then when you Google something
Caption: you always have to pay for something and
Caption: that's not that's not what I want to do
Caption: so it's really it's really good that
Caption: planet offers these free courses for me
Caption: and I don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so I can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work Planet
Caption: always encourages learning and learning
Caption: is a good way to just accelerate your
Caption: career growth Top Line of testing is um
Caption: it's awesome it's it's really cool to be
Caption: around people who are so passionate so
Caption: driven to do what they do and who always
Caption: want to want to learn and get better I
Caption: think that's really important and I
Caption: think it's going to be a driving Factor
Caption: going forward in in the IT industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top world is the best of the best and
Caption: for me it's if you want to grow up in
Caption: your career you are at the right place
Caption: because we have got all the training
Caption: materials right people and right
Caption: opportunities yeah what do you need to
Caption: progress in your career you have got
Caption: everything in here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact fact
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: all right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: um okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: Scott Hanselman and I was told to give
Caption: you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: nerds nerding what we're doing is we're
Caption: talking to people all over the world
Caption: because we're stuck
Caption: it's just like my dream come true I
Caption: always water to join Scott henselman
Caption: true
Caption: what do you want
Caption: oh my God
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while I was gone I made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then I helped him make his work much
Caption: better and we found the perfect outfit
Caption: to wear to my party
Caption: but I really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so I turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying Market leading Technology
Caption: Solutions through our life cycle
Caption: Services we help clients realize
Caption: business outcomes through our advice
Caption: integration and operational services
Caption: mlq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their I.T needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: goodbye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: all right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: um okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: Scott hansman and I was told to give you
Caption: a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: nerds nerding what we're doing is we're
Caption: talking to people all over the world
Caption: because we're stuck in our movies
Caption: foreign
Caption: what do you want
Caption: oh my chocolate
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three more days we need it ASAP okay
Caption: team what's the status on the app we're
Caption: good to go accept our login experience
Caption: is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: flawlessly because because I don't want
Caption: to lose one single customer I hear you
Caption: so let's use off zero off what now off
Caption: zero it's an identity platform fast easy
Caption: logins just what the boss wants can we
Caption: make our own authentication Service come
Caption: on the ultimate keymaster you know we
Caption: don't have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use Siri can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale up but get hit
Caption: with a ton of traffic and if it stalls
Caption: or freezes up I will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep hey
Caption: bigger customers are gonna love it I cut
Caption: a real app now folks
Caption: you know what I want a bodyguard hey we
Caption: got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's Stephen
Caption: what's up Stephen
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: uh okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends I'm Scott hansman and I was
Caption: told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck
Caption: like my dream come true I've always
Caption: wanted a joy and Scott have someone too
Caption: foreign
Caption: what do you want
Caption: oh my chocolate
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a Fearless hunger for
Caption: Success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using AI to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for one
Caption: hundred thousand teammates ambition is
Caption: how a Children's Hospital built an app
Caption: to reduce stress for families ambition
Caption: is how a law firm rallied against a
Caption: malware attack to reclaim control and
Caption: prevent a devastating breach of client
Caption: confidence at Insight we know the power
Caption: of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young Brothers
Caption: to a Fortune 500 company offering I.T
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be now is
Caption: the time to do big things together now
Caption: is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: I'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case it might be
Caption: familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my color sign because I like
Caption: eating I eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating they always
Caption: ask me Carol why are you eating and I
Caption: think that just when they see when they
Caption: see the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: Carol
Caption: I'm a test engineer they call me gesture
Caption: because I always have a smile on my face
Caption: whatever situation I'm in
Caption: my name is Jayden I'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at Planet my core sign is
Caption: digit because I'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major
Caption: um but I often get called out
Caption: on how I never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths I just love maths
Caption: I am Cassandra I am a test at the
Caption: mission especially being very as you can
Caption: tell by Jackson I am French very very
Caption: premium accent so it's a very completely
Caption: makes sense as for the pink no matter as
Caption: a client no matter where I was working
Caption: it always was a bigger background with
Caption: Hello Kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who I am outside
Caption: clearly but I think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: um Sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: buried it is
Caption: my name is Kong I'm a consultant here at
Caption: Planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name I always say I'm
Caption: not the king but the Kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: I am the king and I'm the Kong
Caption: work to inspire it's very something that
Caption: we live by I believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we have for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for Target we
Caption: always try to go a little bit further
Caption: and we try to inspire each other by
Caption: learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and I think
Caption: it's very inspiring be better build
Caption: better personally I always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so I'm better than
Caption: yesterday and I'll be better tomorrow
Caption: but I also got a lot of training
Caption: opportunities and planning because
Caption: there's a
Caption: Farm library of training courses
Caption: available that I can just access anytime
Caption: before I join Planet like when you want
Caption: to learn something go first right and
Caption: then when you Google something you
Caption: always have to pay for something and
Caption: that's not that's not what I want to do
Caption: so it's really it's really good that
Caption: planet offers these free courses for me
Caption: and I don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so I can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work Planet
Caption: always encourages learning and learning
Caption: is a good way to just accelerate your
Caption: career growth Top Line of testing is um
Caption: it's awesome it's it's really cool to be
Caption: around people who are so passionate so
Caption: driven to do what they do and who always
Caption: want to want to learn and get better I
Caption: think that's really important I think
Caption: it's going to be a driving Factor going
Caption: forward in in the IT industry in general
Caption: top world is the best of the best and
Caption: for me it's if you want to grow up in
Caption: your career you are at the right place
Caption: because we have got all the training
Caption: materials right people and right
Caption: opportunities yeah what do you need to
Caption: progress in your career you have got
Caption: everything in here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thank you
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: drum roll please if we can grab our
Caption: seats
Caption: all right I'm really excited about this
Caption: um our next speaker Gia kanatsu which
Caption: I've probably pronounced wrong but I am
Caption: gonna make her my new best friend
Caption: because
Caption: she is not only in early and career
Caption: solution architect at Microsoft an
Caption: immigrant from Thailand an endurance
Caption: athlete a tech Optimizer a stem Advocate
Caption: a tedx speaker a multi award wow a
Caption: multi-award winner of the wit wa 2019
Caption: and NASA space app challenge energy hack
Caption: transport hack wa and The uwa Innovation
Caption: Challenge
Caption: gr empowers her customers in environment
Caption: and sustainability to do more with data
Caption: and AI
Caption: and you will often also find her
Caption: volunteering so over to Gia because you
Caption: are the guru thank you Emma
Caption: okay
Caption: how is our energy level today good
Caption: okay if if if you feel like you're gonna
Caption: sleep that's okay it's gonna be like
Caption: bang bang and then we leave the room
Caption: okay now good afternoon everyone thank
Caption: you um for coming into my talk for the
Caption: next 20 minutes I'm so grateful for you
Caption: to be here before we begin I would like
Caption: to acknowledge our sponsor without them
Caption: would it be possible for us to be here
Caption: today now
Caption: whether you are a leader by position or
Caption: Leader by title this one no by position
Caption: or by title or by spirit this one is for
Caption: you the purpose of my talk today is to
Caption: share my experience
Caption: um an observation from Junior
Caption: perspective Junior who has not just
Caption: survived but thrive in technology
Caption: industry because of all the great Giants
Caption: that have lifted me up and stand on
Caption: their shoulders and I will distill their
Caption: behaviors like great behaviors of my
Caption: Giants based on true story and outly
Caption: immediate actions for you so that you
Caption: know that hey helping early in Korea is
Caption: actually an act you know you don't have
Caption: it's not a now you don't have to become
Caption: you don't have to become a mentor
Caption: sponsor and Advocate simply you just
Caption: simply act and I hope that collectively
Caption: we can keep producing the next great
Caption: generation of leaders in our industry
Caption: hi there I'm Gia I'm an early career
Caption: myself
Caption: um as you said I work at Microsoft as an
Caption: associate Cloud solution architect
Caption: outside of all the things that Emma
Caption: didn't say I am also building a
Caption: community of early in Korea for
Caption: Microsoft Australia New Zealand as well
Caption: if you see this you gotta appreciate my
Caption: drawing come on um this is the
Caption: gingerbread man but actually it's the
Caption: early in Korea okay and outside of the
Caption: job that I get paid to do I also do a
Caption: lot of community work I teach an upscale
Caption: digital skill for other people
Caption: specifically disadvantage students or
Caption: like the minority group of people now
Caption: how did I get here in the first place
Caption: I'm going to take you and we're going to
Caption: turn back time together
Caption: before I joined the taking Hill
Caption: Workforce all right the journey has not
Caption: yet begun they are stood with a piece of
Caption: paper and a koala in my hand smiling at
Caption: a photographer walked out from
Caption: graduation with some basic skill in
Caption: ordinary but limited reality right and I
Caption: was just hoping for the best for my
Caption: future
Caption: after mucking around for a little bit I
Caption: then discovered this unfamiliar place
Caption: called the corporate jungle
Caption: as I enter the covered jungle can
Caption: somebody take this because it was
Caption: supposed to do like
Caption: um speaker posts as I
Caption: as I entered the corporate jungle that
Caption: sticky man that not sticky man why stick
Caption: man is me by the way
Caption: I as I enter a copyright jungle I first
Caption: encountered this word murky water I was
Caption: asked to be untruthful to my value so I
Caption: could go shortcuts through shortcuts and
Caption: then I faced this
Caption: um acid rain of cell doubt and not so
Caption: good enough syndrome right it burned my
Caption: skin and soul and when I thought that I
Caption: was gonna get better on the high guess
Caption: what the world biggest pandemic arrived
Caption: we all sent down to this underground
Caption: bunker don't know what happened there
Caption: but it was like Spiral down so hard to
Caption: climb up anyway eventually I climb up
Caption: out there and I faced the biggest spider
Caption: of my life which is signified the new
Caption: career change so I changed my career at
Caption: first new job looks terrifying but
Caption: actually it was not as terrifying and
Caption: did you know that spider they are
Caption: actually friendly they look terrifying
Caption: but they're friendly
Caption: that's why
Caption: um and with new job came new terrain
Caption: right I was exposed out there
Caption: where trolls could attack me and I
Caption: thought I was gonna die but I survived
Caption: and um despite it all the journey still
Caption: continue but I didn't go through this
Caption: risky and Parable situation by myself
Caption: now in the mainstream media I usually
Caption: say this why oh wizard love mentoring
Caption: and advocating for younger people right
Caption: but
Caption: mentors and Advocates take many forms
Caption: from beautiful Mains to Kung Fu
Caption: instructor to the blue robot cats of the
Caption: 22nd century I don't know if you know
Caption: there are Yemen but I grew up with
Caption: Doraemon I'm from Thailand I grew up
Caption: with Durham and
Caption: two big and friendly giant and there
Caption: enter the giant throughout the journey
Caption: right of risky and Peril situation now
Caption: the Giants that I met they show me the
Caption: way they Lifted Me Up they leveraged
Caption: their high so I could see the path and
Caption: possibility in front of me they provided
Caption: practical training right profound wisdom
Caption: and they push me and they challenge me
Caption: to fight in the new terrain they helped
Caption: me build grit and self-confidence now
Caption: for us here today what I'm gonna do I'm
Caption: going to highlight each of these Giants
Caption: impacts that they have on me and
Caption: behavior is that worth modeling from
Caption: okay
Caption: now first giant Jason Yao Jason's not in
Caption: the room today but and he doesn't work
Caption: at Microsoft by the way Jason was the
Caption: first giant when I was trying to figure
Caption: out what am I doing in technology
Caption: because Tech is so vast no idea what I'm
Caption: doing
Caption: I thought I was not going to go back and
Caption: see Jason yell again because our first
Caption: conversation was so confronting I asked
Caption: can you help me um get a job I I wanted
Caption: to be an I.T or software consultant he
Caption: turned around and say no you don't want
Caption: to be an I.T consultant
Caption: he said that no and he said you don't
Caption: want to be an I.T consultant because you
Caption: don't know what you want to do you say
Caption: that because you don't know what you
Caption: want to do you gotta admit it and I was
Caption: like what excuse me how dare you burst
Caption: my bubble how dare you how dare you tell
Caption: me what I want and what I don't want so
Caption: you say okay before we come back and
Caption: meet each other again
Caption: you gotta list out okay 100 jobs in
Caption: technology and do your resume as if it
Caption: were to be in the year of 2050 and come
Caption: back and talk to me and I was like 20 50
Caption: oh 30 years from then okay okay um well
Caption: I'm not gonna do that but guess what I
Caption: did it I did the resume right list out
Caption: all the job I went through that exercise
Caption: and really do the research and trying to
Caption: understand what it means and I was like
Caption: hey Jason was right I didn't want to be
Caption: an I.T consultant I said that because
Caption: everybody at uwa said they want to be an
Caption: I.T consultant all my peers say they
Caption: want to be a consultant now you know
Caption: without that exercise I wouldn't break
Caption: free from the traditional thinking right
Caption: we wouldn't think for myself what we can
Caption: learn or this deal from Jason's Story
Caption: here is that you as a leader of today
Caption: you have to challenge the initial belief
Caption: of your Junior so you help them disrupt
Caption: their traditional way of thinking that
Caption: might not be true and then they can
Caption: think for themselves or develop critical
Caption: thinking skills now my next giant is
Caption: Kirsten Kirsten gurgeon sorry Kirsten
Caption: Gerson
Caption: of course I know her name but anyways it
Caption: was hard to get a job in Tech at first
Caption: like in in Tech in Australia especially
Caption: being an international student so kg
Caption: helped me get my first job in Tech right
Caption: she was so well connected she loved um
Caption: connecting people together she pushed so
Caption: hard to actually lend me the first job
Caption: at the Cisco partner company
Caption: I get to test what it's like to work in
Caption: Tech right and that opportunity was so
Caption: important to me to learn that hey
Caption: employment was a two-way street
Caption: as much as I want to be employed I also
Caption: have to evaluate my employer value as
Caption: well so I later left that partner
Caption: company because I valued it online
Caption: but what we can learn from kg here is
Caption: leverage your extensive network to help
Caption: your Junior land that opportunity to
Caption: help your Junior get their first job or
Caption: or wherever they want to go right if you
Caption: know somebody that you can connect them
Caption: with do that
Caption: now
Caption: oh my God she's not here anymore what
Caption: anyway so my third giant is Michelle
Caption: Sanford
Caption: I could I actually could make the whole
Caption: day conference about Michelle but I'm
Caption: not going to do that
Caption: I only have 20 minutes
Caption: um so so Michelle
Caption: let me borrow her belief in me
Caption: when I landed my job well when I landed
Caption: myself in Microsoft it was about eight
Caption: months in I was a grad right I knew
Caption: nothing about powerapps if you don't
Caption: know powerapps it's a product Microsoft
Caption: owns um powerapps and I knew nothing
Caption: about running a workshop I knew nothing
Caption: about anything literally because I was
Caption: still learning the world Microsoft and
Caption: Michelle yet vollen told me right to run
Caption: a one-day workshop for international
Caption: women's day and we invite like a lot of
Caption: women from not-for-profit organization
Caption: to come and learn power apps
Caption: surely you say gee are you not the only
Caption: person at Microsoft they're going to be
Caption: other people she walk up to me she's
Caption: like Gia you are the last person
Caption: standing
Caption: I believe you can do this oh there you
Caption: go Michelle hello
Caption: and
Caption: I was like I was so stressed out right I
Caption: was like to be honest I was scared as
Caption:  out of me excuse my language but I
Caption: only have three days to to you know
Caption: learn the power apps and write up the
Caption: screen prepare the environment
Caption: everything I was like what am I doing
Caption: and Michelle actually went to another
Caption: party so thanks Michelle but anyways
Caption: um I was so stressed but
Caption: in the end everything went well thank
Caption: you very much because without that
Caption: opportunity I wouldn't know that hey an
Caption: early in career like me just landed
Caption: eight weeks into Microsoft can actually
Caption: make an impact already right so what we
Caption: can learn from Michelle here is you have
Caption: to give your Junior challenges for them
Caption: to solve right
Caption: so they can build up their confidence as
Caption: they learn to handle and overcome those
Caption: challenges
Caption: all right
Caption: is is she in the room
Caption: hello hi Antonette so Antoinette is my
Caption: phone giant so I would feel lost in the
Caption: world pandemic without internet I join
Caption: Microsoft as a grad right and we were
Caption: supposed to go through this like Canada
Caption: they flew us to be together mucking
Caption: around trying to find out how to do
Caption: stuff in corporate jungle and meet
Caption: Microsoft Executives and potentially
Caption: this this is what I was thinking they
Caption: probably like installed chip in our
Caption: brain so that you know we all get
Caption: brainwashed and like oh my God Microsoft
Caption: anyway that did not happen that did not
Caption: happen because everything got canceled a
Caption: week before we flew remember at that
Caption: time
Caption: thanks
Caption: anyways I was like oh my god
Caption: um it did not happen because the world
Caption: remember that time we had time where we
Caption: went into the lockdown and the
Caption: everything went virtual remember it was
Caption: a weird time so I we just like what what
Caption: happened like what anyways unfortunately
Caption: a lot of people in the younger like
Caption: Workforce they feel lost in this
Caption: transition because they haven't grabbed
Caption: the um the concept of work yet they
Caption: still learning their job and also they
Caption: have to learn the new way of being
Caption: undoing so I felt lost in that
Caption: transition too now during lockdown I was
Caption: going through family member loss and um
Caption: some issues so I kind of grounded myself
Caption: worth in work I do nothing else I only
Caption: work right I only work and I thought it
Caption: was everything I had because hey I
Caption: deserve a spot at Microsoft therefore I
Caption: I have to show this to everybody but
Caption: actually it's not really true anyways
Caption: internet comes in
Caption: she let me out of that downward bunker
Caption: spiral if you saw in the beginning
Caption: um Anto been working at Microsoft for a
Caption: while she know ins and outs and
Caption: everything she noticed my garment and
Caption: she's like oh you run I say yeah we
Caption: start running together we um starting
Caption: training for half our men together and
Caption: during those training right she would
Caption: also coach me to navigate like difficult
Caption: work situations or you know show me the
Caption: bigger picture of Microsoft of like hey
Caption: this is what we have been we did it
Caption: before the pandemic arrived you know or
Caption: give me like harsh feedback not harsh
Caption: honest feedback there you go honest
Caption: feedback
Caption: sorry honest feedback and you know like
Caption: and until one day I just realized that
Caption: oh my God everybody around me said hey
Caption: Gia you've been brainwashed by Microsoft
Caption: even my parents
Caption: and I actually truly believe that I
Caption: found my place at my Microsoft and a few
Caption: belong and I love this company now it's
Caption: not about
Caption: this is not about Microsoft talk but I'm
Caption: just gonna keep pushing on just to let
Caption: you know that I meet really great people
Caption: there and what we can learn from
Caption: internet here is that you have
Caption: is suddenly okay you have to connect
Caption: with your Junior outside of work so that
Caption: you know you form that friendship and
Caption: you create that sense of belonging for
Caption: them okay sometimes it's a really lonely
Caption: place the corporate jungle
Caption: my next giant hello Jonathan
Caption: hi Jonathan so Jonathan Wade when I
Caption: decided to change my career from account
Caption: management into class solution architect
Caption: I don't know if you know about the two
Caption: careers like this two separate way it
Caption: doesn't go the same like it's super
Caption: technical and super not technical
Caption: um so many people ask me how did you do
Caption: that within a year at Microsoft I
Caption: wouldn't be able to do that without
Caption: Jonathan way so Jonathan is our director
Caption: of Microsoft Azure in Australia New
Caption: Zealand he believed in diversity of
Caption: thoughts and you know how like solution
Caption: architect they always hide 10 15 years
Caption: experienced people to come into the role
Caption: resulted in similar way of thinking they
Caption: went to the same school read the same
Caption: set book textbooks
Caption: because
Caption: sorry the same textbook
Caption: English is my second language
Caption: this textbook
Caption: um and you know like basically similar
Caption: way of thinking and he was like no we're
Caption: gonna give like different people that
Caption: have different different year of
Caption: experience to come into the role and
Caption: then we're gonna get people with
Caption: different backgrounds as well it doesn't
Caption: matter if they have technical experience
Caption: it's okay we're gonna do this associate
Caption: Cloud solution architect program so he
Caption: was pushing hard for that and without
Caption: Jonathan I wouldn't be in the role that
Caption: I am today
Caption: so thank you very much what we can learn
Caption: from Jonathan here is that if you have
Caption: the privilege of any Source Right Use
Caption: Your Privilege to create the space and
Caption: time for diversity and inclusion to
Caption: emerge
Caption: my six and seven giants
Caption: um anyways
Caption: there are two key people that help me
Caption: actually get
Caption: um into the role as well Michael and
Caption: Morgan when I actually saw the solution
Caption: architect role come up I call Michael
Caption: which is my ex-boss now I say hey
Caption: Michael um I saw this opportunity of
Caption: lifetime I applied I didn't really tell
Caption: them I I just told them I apply please
Caption: support me Michael looked at me with
Caption: this belief like on team's call and he
Caption: was like how dare you like that was on
Caption: his face because he has to go through
Caption: like Recruitment and everything right
Caption: but he did not sabotage my career at all
Caption: he actually supported me throughout
Caption: until I was a successful candidate and
Caption: when I got the offer of the solution
Caption: architect I saw my number went up like
Caption: it got bummed up and I was like oh this
Caption: must be something wrong
Caption: I call Morgan and they say hey Morgan
Caption: um I have no experience just need to
Caption: make sure that this is the right number
Caption: and it's like no no because of your
Caption: impact that you create in the last year
Caption: at Microsoft
Caption: this is a fair compensation for you and
Caption: I was like oh really thank you very much
Caption: thank you for looking after me and what
Caption: we can learn from these two giants is
Caption: that first you have to invest in the
Caption: growth and the development of your
Caption: Junior and secondly
Caption: you must fight for a fair compensation
Caption: for them in relation to the ability to
Caption: create impact not because of their years
Caption: of experience
Caption: now
Caption: my Adrian daniela's Matthew remember the
Caption: associate class solution architect that
Caption: Jonathan was trying to push for Daniela
Caption: who is on the was on the ground doing
Caption: the work set up the program set up the
Caption: structure around it so that the
Caption: associate that coming later know what
Caption: they're doing and they're about four
Caption: Associates in our business right now we
Caption: spend less time mucking around they're
Caption: trying to like learn technical stuff we
Caption: just we know this there's a path in
Caption: front of us and what we need to do
Caption: because the nail has been there before
Caption: what we can learn from Daniel is here is
Caption: that if you if possible pave the path
Caption: for them pave the path for your Junior
Caption: make it easier for them to follow don't
Caption: don't make it hard for them you know
Caption: like career in itself is just already
Caption: hard
Caption: now Rivage so revash I had to learn a
Caption: lot of technical concept first six
Caption: months oh my God my brand was swollen
Caption: and what I really appreciate about
Caption: Rivage is that he will spend hours an
Caption: hour learning the concept that he
Caption: doesn't know with me like data
Caption: governance just to make sure that hey I
Caption: can actually develop my skills right and
Caption: I still have so much to learn so much to
Caption: improve but you know I am now more
Caption: confident in my technical skill than a
Caption: year ago and that would not be possible
Caption: without revage now my last giant promise
Caption: I promise is it the last one oh sorry no
Caption: what we can learn from reverse here
Caption: sorry we have to have the technical or
Caption: domain expertise and be willing to learn
Caption: and grow with your Junior okay because
Caption: technology is an ever increasing
Caption: landscape
Caption: now my last giant Sergio so remember
Caption: like that I don't know how many people
Caption: have done the conferences live demo and
Caption: stuff she'd always go wrong things
Caption: doesn't work right you probably have
Caption: seen it so many times today
Caption: that happened to me too I was just so
Caption: stressed out and oh my God I cannot even
Caption: talk properly and one day I actually
Caption: delivered my first workshop and I got
Caption: the feedback in the feedback form and
Caption: say how we spent a lot of money at
Caption: Microsoft how dare you send the junior
Caption: person to teach us she wasted our time
Caption: and I was like wow that deflated me
Caption: because I actually spent a lot of effort
Caption: on that but Sergio came in and I was
Caption: like hey I have extensive experience in
Caption: this let's run the workshop together so
Caption: we do so many in so many so many
Caption: together until today I can actually run
Caption: my live demos I can do conference haul I
Caption: can't do
Caption: um whatever things that I need to stand
Caption: up in front of people and talk
Caption: um and that would not be possible
Caption: without Sergio
Caption: so what we can learn from Sergio here is
Caption: hey if they have not done it before let
Caption: them fight with you for a while right
Caption: let them fly with you until they can fly
Caption: solo
Caption: now out of all of these what I noticed
Caption: they have what they have um the insides
Caption: of all the Giants is that it's not just
Caption: you know their PS it's not just people
Caption: on the team it takes a village it's not
Caption: just one person you might say there's so
Caption: many Giants that's the point because you
Caption: have so many people that you can
Caption: leverage and and you know get the help
Caption: from
Caption: and it has to go up to the manager and
Caption: the sponsor level as well right
Caption: okay promise Cup last couple slides tick
Caption: tick tick
Caption: um
Caption: we know it's hard to start out I don't
Caption: have to say this but we all know that
Caption: it's hard to start out hitting the
Caption: ground running catching up with the
Caption: people that have been in industry for a
Caption: while right and the expectation to solve
Caption: like the complex problems are ever
Caption: increasing in technology now if we don't
Caption: have or provide without proper support
Caption: or close support for your Junior it's
Caption: like they are going through this loss in
Caption: transition
Caption: in their growth and transformation
Caption: without losses like this
Caption: you're sending them out to slay the
Caption: dragon in the first episode you are
Caption: sending them you are setting them up for
Caption: a failure right but it doesn't have to
Caption: be like that it should be learning from
Caption: the wise and shattering The Experience
Caption: one because they've been there before
Caption: now I'm gonna skip it but you know what
Caption: if you want to take photo take the photo
Caption: so you might ask me like okay look for
Caption: potential because not everybody is fully
Caption: developed right not everybody so look
Caption: for potential
Caption: now that there's no greater gift than
Caption: the gift of growth what I want you to do
Caption: now pull out your phone right now pull
Caption: your phone come on pour out your phone
Caption: who are your phone
Caption: go to your to-do list of choice and I'm
Caption: sure when I when you are listening to me
Caption: talking just now right some someone's
Caption: name pops up
Caption: write the name of that Junior person
Caption: down write that name down your to-do
Caption: list of choice and next to that person
Caption: and if you are junior write a name of
Caption: the person that you want to you know
Caption: reach out to you okay next to that
Caption: person name for the later in Korea write
Caption: this down I will help you slay the
Caption: dragon in the corporate jungle
Caption: okay if you're a junior say I need your
Caption: help slaying the dragon Monday comes
Caption: okay Monday comes the name that you
Caption: wrote down reach out to them set up
Caption: one-on-one coffee ketchup bubble tea
Caption: whatever you know and let them know that
Caption: you're here that you need help that you
Caption: need help for junior that you can help
Caption: them offer that help when they ask for
Caption: help listen carefully okay and I
Caption: understand we cannot take everybody on
Caption: their shoulder on our shoulder right
Caption: find the right Junior that you can
Caption: connect and Vibe with it's like it's
Caption: like dating app it's take a while it
Caption: takes like sorry it's wrong context but
Caption: you know it's relationship has to take
Caption: two ways takes two ways so this person
Caption: Monday might not be the person you can't
Caption: connect with that's okay next month you
Caption: do it again keep finding the person that
Caption: you can you know connect with
Caption: all right last slides
Caption: season finale
Caption: today I'm still in the journey in the
Caption: corporate jungle but I am at the full
Caption: capacity I owe all the Giants the
Caption: confidence that I now have in myself
Caption: without them I wouldn't turn out to be
Caption: so awesome
Caption: um
Caption: so as I stand as I stand on the shoulder
Caption: of Giants and look at the path in front
Caption: of me I know that I'm ready to take on
Caption: new quests you know and continue to make
Caption: my mark in this terrain and Beyond thank
Caption: you very much
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: that's okay that is a summary if anybody
Caption: wants to take the photos it's just too
Caption: wordy but I was about to say can you
Caption: leave that up so I can take a photo too
Caption: please
Caption: um Gia that was fantastic
Caption: um as always I will come see you a
Caption: little bit later and probably bug you on
Caption: a few things just a heads up guys we've
Caption: got afternoon tea
Caption: um so that's in the Riverside foia or
Caption: the North and South and just a friendly
Caption: reminder please be in the theater by 405
Caption: for the lock note
Caption: thank you and well done again Jaya
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: foreign
Caption: Mark where are you Mark open your turn
Caption: your camera on uh
Caption: uh okay you can you can see me yeah yeah
Caption: we can see you
Caption: hey friends I'm Scott Hanselman and I
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our places
Caption: foreign
Caption: what do you want
Caption: oh my chocolate
Caption: [Music]
Caption: questions
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three more days we need it ASAP okay
Caption: team what's the status on the app we're
Caption: good to go accept our login experience
Caption: is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: flawlessly because because I don't want
Caption: to lose one single customer I hear you
Caption: so let's use off zero off what now off
Caption: zero it's an identity platform fast easy
Caption: logins just what the boss wants can we
Caption: make our own authentication Service come
Caption: on the Ultimate key master you know we
Caption: don't have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use oh Siri can do that yeah but
Caption: it needs to be secure we can't have our
Caption: app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale up but get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up I will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep I think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it I got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what I want a bodyguard hey we
Caption: got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's Stephen
Caption: what's up Steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]